Es noch mal schnell mal ein Brötchen fertig, lull.
So sieht es aus, lull wie größer Kekwe.
Mikro zuerst ist auch am Start, lull.
So sieht es aus, lull.
So sieht es aus, lull wie größer Kekwe.
Der Chat fliegt jetzt rein hinten. Habt ihrs gesehen? Der Chat ist reingeflogen.
Big Brain pre-aimed. Es ist erstaunlich wie gut die alten Battlefield
Games noch aussehen.
Was ist das eigentlich für Zulul Musik gerade?
Okay, er trifft schon mal nicht. Okay, das war echt Big Brain Glück.
Neko-chan sagt, by the way, Name, wenn Battlefield 3 ordentlich Mod-Support, Custom-Map-Support
hätte, dann wäre das Game nicht tot zu kriegen.
Ich glaube trotzdem, dass Battlefield 4 sich da besser eignen würde für, weil es einfach
mittlerweile ein Ticken moderner ist, weil es noch umfangreicher ist. Das Einzige, was
mir bei Battlefield 4 abgeht, sind gute Rush-Maps und das hätte sich mit Custom-Mod und Map-Support
erledigt, weil da hätten bestimmt schon ein paar Leute die einen oder anderen guten
Rush-Maps zusammen gewurstet bzw. die originalen Maps umgebaut.
Wo ist das M-Com? Ach, das ist Rush, äh, das ist das Conquest. Alter, die werden ja weg.
Gekickt? Er wird gekickt oder irgendwas. Ja, das kann ja schon mal passieren. Wobei das
wahrscheinlich gar nicht an Dice liegt, sondern an der Internetverbindung von dem Typ.
Ach, guck mal da. Nose-Hair-Cannons. Oh, haha, geil. Moment, man kann Gegner killen, indem
er ihnen auf den Kopf springt. Was zum? Ok, man kann da abheben, alles klar. Weiß nicht
viel Logik. Ok, wie auch immer er das überlebt hat. Und der Headshot hat noch einen. Moin,
Captain Seekai. He, die checken wir wieder, wieder richtig viel, die Gegner. Console-Grafics.
Äh, äh, was, was? Moment, das hab ich nicht gecheckt. Was? What? What? What? My iPad
Bad Company 2 Musik. Bad Company 2 hat aber auch einen geilen Soundtrack. Und eins, eins
auch. Das ist sogar Bad Company 1 glaube, was da läuft nicht zwei. Battlefield-Physics.
Was? Das geht? Man kann die Rakete snipen. Oh, geil. Wusstet ihr das? Wusstet ihr, dass
man die Rakete snipen kann? Ich nicht. Ich dachte, das ist halt irgendein, das Geschoss
wird quasi nur so der Form halber eingeblendet, dass es so aussieht, als würde da wirklich
was fliegen und das Game handelt das Intern ganz anders. Aber das ist wirklich ein richtig
echtes Projektil mit Hitbox und Detection und allem. Wie fandest du eigentlich Battlefield
1, äh, ich mein Fall gewesen. Hab ich mir gar nicht gekauft. Wow. What? Ok, ich hab
wieder legit keine Ahnung, was er gerade gekillt hat. What? Ich hab keine Ahnung, was der da
gerade killt. Das ist doch die Map, wo sie sich so gefeiert haben, dass die Wellen synchronisiert
sind. Oh. Warum auch immer, dass der Typ gerade überlebt hat. Der Chat ist ihm voll ins Gesicht
geflogen. Oh, nice. Oh, das ist cool. Doppelt, doppelt, äh, RPG-Stats. So, das ist wieder
so ein typischer Fall von Heli fliegt exakt in die Rakete. PlayStation Graphics. Das sieht
so hässlich aus, das könnte sogar PS3 sein. Der fliegt voll rein. Bam. Und das ist PC
mit 5 FPS. Ok, das ist auch mehr Glück als verstanden. Der guckt lieber gar nicht hin.
Das war die Map mit der sinnlosesten Revolution aller Zeiten, die war einfach nur drin, dass
sie in Revolution bewerben konnten. Alter, der hat ja immer die krasseste Color Correction
drauf, äh. Das sieht aus, als will er Battlefield 4 aussehen lassen wie Battlefield 3 mit Blaustich.
Oder? Das ist wirklich, dass sie Battlefield 4 auf Battlefield 3 gemacht, vom Blaustich
her. Hast du im As-Effect-Spiel? Ja. Du bist gerade an der ESX so hyper wie Migration.
Ja dann, GLHF. Äh. Hahaha, in your face. Oh, die Map hab ich so gern gespielt, ich hab
schon vergessen, wie sie heißt. Äh. Hab vergessen, wie sie heißt. Das die mit dem
Motel am Ende. Wo das M, Motel liegt. Das ist genau das Battlefield 2 Remake. Ja, genau.
Die Gegner haben wieder, die Gegner helfen. Ok, springt er jetzt in den Heli rein? Mit
dem, mit dem, mit dem Jeep. Oh, das ist ja cool. Das sind so Sachen, die, das, das war
eine der Sachen, die das, die an Battlefield 3, 4, bisschen auch Bad Company 1, 2 so geil
waren, dass solche Sachen einfach so dynamisch ergeben haben. Dass das nicht gescriptet war,
dass du teilweise selbst es noch nicht mal so richtig vorhattest, sondern so im letzten
Moment gedacht hast, ah das könnte klappen, hast es gemacht, das hat eins von zehnmal
geklappt und dann war das nice. Die ganzen kleinen Snipers. Bam und wieder rein. Und wo
ist der Hit? Da muss man auch doch ein bisschen Glück haben dabei. Oh, Bazaar. Da hab ich
schlechte Erinnerung dran von der letzten Runde. Hey, Triple, Triple Headshot Collateral,
wie haben sich denn da die Gegner bitte schon aufgereiht? Oh, Triple, Triple, Triple. Oh,
das ist nice. Wie er sich freut. Das sind coole Kills gewesen. Ich mein, was man öfters
sieht, sind wir springen aus dem Jet, nehmen den RPG, schießen die Gegner ab, aber wir
springen aus dem Jet, nehmen die Sniper und snipen den gegnerischen Pilot raus. Das ist
schon Next Level Big Brain Action. E-Console Graphics wieder.
Kriegt er ein S-Geballert. Ja, so Dinger gibt es öfters, so Clips. Wenn er jetzt noch
wieder in den Chat richtig, also so Clips hat man schon öfters gesehen, richtig extrem
krass wäre der Clip gewesen, wäre er jetzt rückwärts noch wieder im Chat gelandet.
So, diese Droppot Map. Man sich fragt, was haben sie sich dabei gedacht. By the way,
bevor wir fertig gucken, wir müssen gerade mal schauen, Steam Stats. Steam Stats für
Battlefield 4. Ok, das geht auch. Battlefield 4. Ist das nicht Steam Stats? Ach, Steam Charts.
Battlefield 3. Steam DB Info, das meine ich, richtig. Das da. Das hier geht auch. Also
haben wir mal einen Monat. Nicht ganz einen Monat draußen. So, ähm. Achso, das Battlefield
3. Ich wollte gerade sagen, das ist ein bisschen wenig, ne. Battlefield 4. Ja, gut, das geht
ein bisschen runter, ist klar. Die Leute haben jetzt auch festgestellt, es sackt ja komplett
über Steam zu spielen, weil man immer noch Origin braucht. Äh, Update. Gibt's den mehr.
Aber Battlefield 4 kann man wohl deutlich besser spielen als Battlefield 3. Wo ist das
Video? Ah, hier. Beim Battlefield 3 kann man immer auch noch ganz gut spielen, aber da
gibt's wirklich wenig Server. Oh, der war gut. Der war, der war nice. Das sieht man auch
selten, dass man einen Revolver-Pilot-Kill kriegt. Man findet keine Rush Server in Battlefield
4. Ja, Rush hat ja in Battlefield 4 auch ein bisschen gesackt, deswegen spiele ich ja auch
lieber Battlefield 3. Ui. Nice collateral. Haha, ok. Ok, Moment, das ist Hardline. Boah,
das, die Gegner. Ah, das tut weh, das tut weh beim Zugucken, Gegner. Ah, da haben wir
einen so zerstört. Ja. Und warum sind die Gegner so absolut braindead? Huge flank. Inklusive
braindead-Gegner. Ist das Konsole oder ist das PC? Also, ich würde sagen, PC von der
Vira spielt und so, aber. Ach, Moment, das Game hatte keinen Chat auf der PS, auf der
Konsole, ne? Kein In-Game-Chat. Zumindest hat keiner den In-Game-Chat verwendet. Die
sind so blöd. Das ist jetzt Playstation. Die sind so unknapplich bescheuert. Das kannst
du dir ja damit angucken.
Die Shotgun-Action. Und außerdem hat genau die Konsole richtig Motion Blur immer. Building
a console killer in 2020. Also, ganz ehrlich, um einen PC zu bauen, der stärker ist als
eine Konsole in 2020, ist nicht das Problem. Man muss gucken, wenn dann PS5 und Xbox Series
X oder so rauskommt, ob man einen PC bauen kann, der ähnlich leistungsfähig ist bei
ähnlichem Preis. Das ist ja die Frage. Also, ich meine, wenn ich mir eine Playstation
für 500 Euro oder so, 4-500 Euro kaufe und versus einen PC, der 2500 kostet, antreten
lasse, dann ist das ja nicht so wirklich der Vergleich, ne? Was ist das? Choose my name?
Zeig mal. Der hätte, der hätte einen Text-to-Speech nehmen müssen, der sich andere wieder G-Man,
wenn es für Valve-Programmierer ist. Ja, das ist ja normal, so Comments. So Dinger
gibt es bei uns auch. Was bei uns auch ganz beliebt ist, wenn dann irgendwo drin steht
so was wie nach dem Motto, das ist ein Hack oder das ist quick and dirty und muss ordentlich
gemacht werden und so Sachen. Das steht bei uns auch total oft drin. Ja, so Geduld steht
bei uns auch mehr oder weniger so oder so ähnlich drin. Ja, vollkommen okay, also das
ist, das ist ja echt nichts Außergewöhnliches. Silver Dark, 6 Monate, Dankeschön, excellent.
Subscription, ich find den, mein Button nicht, big brain sub, Dankeschön. Na und?
Ja, das ist auch immer toll, das muss später von jemand gefixt werden, da kann es von
ausgehen, nein, das fixt nie jemand.
Ja, das ist doch, also, das ist doch jetzt alles noch im Rahmen, ja. Ist doch alles,
ist doch alles noch halbwegs normal. Nee, Herz93, das geht mir auch sonst wo vorbei,
das juckt mich überhaupt nicht. Ich weiß nur, dass der Typ da schon seit, keine Ahnung,
3 Jahren dran rumgewurstet und massig Patreon Geld absahnt. So, wir gucken uns jetzt, das
Video wird mir seit einer Woche schon empfohlen, es hat ja nicht umsonst oder noch länger,
keine Ahnung, okay seit 5 ist es am Start. Kennst du Doom Crossing? Ja, das gucken wir
uns jetzt an. Versahnt du endlich mal Patreon Geld ab? Patreon ist out, wenn schon Onlyfans.
Wenn schon, wenn schon Onlyfans. Der Entwickler von diesem VVVV, ah Dings hier, das mit den
Aliens, dieses 2D Ding, ja, hat sein Code, wo ein Switch Case mit 5000 Cases drin ist,
ja, warum nicht? Kann man machen, sollte man nicht, kann man aber machen. Moment, das
ist zu, zu leise. Jetzt Lautstärke, okay. Wer schreibt schon den Wörth? Soll ich mal
sehen, wie der Deckard Cain verschnitzt sein, ne?
Also, die allererste, aller, allererste Aufguss davon.
Bis sie dann irgendwann auf die Idee gekommen sind, ist es doch keine so gute Idee, wir
machen das Echtzeit.
Warum, dass das stimmt, man kann bei Blizzard
nicht sagen, ab hier, ab hier ist es scheiße geworden, aber man kann es, man finde ich,
man kann es doch ganz gut, also man kann sich das glaube ich ganz gut erklären, warum das
so ein langsamer, nennen wir es mal, Zerfall, Verfall war. Und zwar seit die Activision Blizzard
Geschichte am Start war. Damals wurde ich ja noch geflamed in einem Video, wo ich gesagt
habe, oh je, das habe ich 2011 oder irgendwann schon erzählt, so nach dem Motto, okay, eigentlich
ist das ein Laden und Blizzard wird es auch noch abkriegen. Und da haben die Leute gesagt,
nein, das hat damit überhaupt nichts zu tun, Blizzard und Activision, die haben nur den
Namen zusammen und das ist ja nicht so, als hätte der eine beim anderen was zu sagen und
was auch immer. Ich bin da an sich der langsame Verfall kam mit daher, dass bei diesem Zusammenschluss
Activision Blizzard immer mehr Positionen mit, sagen wir mal, Fan-orientierten, Game-orientierten
Leuten, denen es quasi um die Spiele ging, immer mehr ersetzt wurden durch irgendwelche
BWL-Stonks-Menschen, vielleicht von Activision, vielleicht von sonst woher, die, das war ein
schleichender Prozess, die halt keine Ahnung mehr von Games haben. Letztendlich Leute,
die dann auch, ich weiß, das ist jetzt eine ganz andere Ecke, die auch so Dinge wie Anthem
entscheiden. Ich weiß, das hat mit Activision Blizzard nichts zu tun, aber, ja. Und so Leute,
so und so ähnliche Leute, haben sich dann auch bei Blizzard breit gemacht. Viele Gute
sind weg, sind auf der eigenen Firma, der Blizzard-Chef ist auch weg, der ehemalige. Das war so ein
schleichender, schleichender Verfall, wenn die wichtigen Positionen quasi immer mehr
durch Stonks-Leute ersetzt werden. Da kann das, es gab, ja egal, gucken wir mal weiter.
The Decline of Blizzard is not a story about a successful business that is now failing,
but rather a business that continues to fail its fans. Blizzard was one of my favorite game
developers of all time. My love for this company started when I was like 5 years old, and I've
been giving them more than a decades worth of support. Blizzard, yes me lord, Nintendo,
Bungie, these were the companies I knew of growing up as a kid. All of them were gods
in my eyes. Nothing makes me feel old quite like reminiscing on the first time I ever
played a real computer game. You know, sitting there with Pajama Sam, Freddy Fish, Math Blaster,
Dad bursts into the room, sits me down and says son, you're almost 5 years old, but you've
irgendwie, auf dem Bild, wasch also mal, irgendwie sieht das ein bisschen aus wie der Postel,
wie der Postel Dude, oder? Down and says son, you're almost 5 years old, but you've got
a lot of manning up to do. It's time for a real game. Hands me Starcraft and it was
like I'm Harry Potter grabbing the wand that was destined for me. I have so many vivid memories
of playing the single player campaign, custom games. Ich hab so gesucked im Multiplayer
von Starcraft. Ich hab damals relativ viel Multiplayer gespielt, teilweise noch mit Modem
am Anfang, glaube war das sogar, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Das war die Zeit wo
Battle.net noch richtig geil war in Form von einfach das was die Spieler sich gewünscht
haben. Das Battle.net damals war so ein mysteriöser Ort irgendwie mit Chaträumen und wo dann
auch aus einem Spiel Leute in den Chatraum und Lobbies von anderen Spielen reinjoinen
konnten. Also du konntest zum Beispiel, wenn du Diablo aufhattest, oder Diablo 2 hattest
du auf, dann konntest du in den Starcraft Raum joinen, oder ein Starcraft Spieler konnte
in den Diablo Raum joinen, dann hatte der einen Diablo Charakter unten und du hattest
einen Starcraft Charakter. Das war richtig geil eigentlich. Ja und ich hab damals auch
relativ viel Multiplayer gespielt, aber ich hab so krass gesucked, wenn man mal ehrlich
ist. Hast du trotzdem Bock gemacht? Ja. Das stimmt. Also Cinematics können sie und Cinematics
können sie bis heute gut. Das war das Intro zu Brute War? Kann ich mich überhaupt nicht
mehr dran erinnern? Erinnert mich eher hier dran so gerade.
Haha. Ja. Haha. Ja.
Das war schon ein krasser Run, wenn man sich das überlegt, was die damals rausgebracht
haben. Also wenn man sich überlegt, die haben ja, die haben so Sachen wie Diablo, Starcraft,
Warcraft 3, die haben ja Dinge rausgehauen in Folge, wo du dir eigentlich gedacht hast,
ok die können nichts schlechtes machen, das geht gar nicht. Und die Spieler haben einfach
instinktiv und intuitiv so viel richtig gemacht und ich glaube das liegt zum größten Teil
daran, weil die Entwickler das selbst gespielt haben. Weil die Entwickler kein Spiel gemacht
haben für die Stonks, sondern weil die Entwickler ein Spiel gemacht haben, was sie selbst gerne
spielen wollen. Und so lange dran rumgebaut haben, bis nichts mehr dabei war, was ihnen
auf den Sack gegangen ist und quasi alles dabei war, was sie selbst gerne spielen wollen.
Ach du Scheiße, ja. Ja.
Mit dieser Episode so viele Leute, die keine Ahnung von Online-Games hatten, kennen seit
dem World of Warcraft und jeder, der selbst mit Computersachen online spielen und so nichts
zu tun hat, kennt die South Park World of Warcraft Episode. Ich hab auch mal WoW gespielt,
aber ich hab nicht viel World of Warcraft gespielt, muss ich sagen. Ein bisschen nebenbei,
aber es war nie so mein MMO. Ich hab damals Dark Age of Camelot gespielt. Jahrelang,
ewig lang. Seit 2003 oder so, bis 2013 oder lang. Ja, das stimmt. Vor allem, die hatten
ja damals, man konnte in Warcraft, in Starcraft und ich glaube auch in den anderen Warcraft
Teilen, konnte man ja jede Einheit mehrfach anklicken und die haben dann irgendwie eine
doofe Sprüche abgelassen. Das fand ich halt auch schon geil, dass jede Einheit nicht nur
diese Standard-Dinger hat, Yes Commander, Yes Commander und so nach dem Motto, sondern
jede eine hatte irgendwie bis zu 10 Custom Sprüche, die nur gekommen sind, wenn man
draufklickt. Ja gut, das stimmt. Overwatch ist auch ein typisches Ding für, wo man
sieht, dass teilweise, zumindest zum damaligen Zeitpunkt, noch Leute bei Blizzard am Start
sind, die gute Games machen können, aber wo es schon in der Umsetzung und im weiteren
Handling komplett verschissen wird. Falcoman, moin. Wenn ich den Typ sehe, krieg ich Anfälle,
das ist nämlich der, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr euch da noch dran erinnern könnt, ich hab
ja damals ein bisschen World of Warcraft gespielt, als das rausgekommen ist und ich hab ein bisschen
auf Nostalrius gespielt, das war so ein Classic-Free-Shard. Der war echt cool, für Leute wie mich,
die nie großartig World of Warcraft-Klassik gespielt haben, war das ganz nice. Der Typ
hat mal gesagt in einem Interview, dass die alten World of Warcraft-Versionen schlechter
sind als die neuen und hat als Beispiel angeführt und jetzt kommt eines der Sachen, die für
mich, deswegen ist er auch komplett unten durch, der Niedergang von MMOs schlechthin sind.
Der hat gesagt in einem Interview, dass man früher in MMOs die Leute für Raids, für
Dungeons, für Group-Content sich zusammensuchen musste und heute kann man einfach den Dungeon-Finder
verwenden. Wie kann jemand sowas gut finden in dieser Position? Ich mein, ist es klar,
warum die das geil finden, weil mehr Kacknoobs Zugang zum Game finden, ich weiß es nicht,
aber ohne Scheiß Leute, Dungeon-Finder, das Einführen vom Dungeon-Finder, das war ja
was, was sich nicht nur in World of Warcraft durchgezogen hat, sondern dadurch, dass World
of Warcraft so der Trendsetter schlechthin ist, was MMOs angeht, haben das fast alle
Games gemacht und ohne Scheiß Dungeon-Finder ist der Anfang vom Ende von guten MMOs gewesen.
Was ist denn ein Dungeon-Finder? Da muss ich dir erklären, wie du das früher gemacht
hast. Früher warst du in einer Gilde oder hast dich vielleicht über einen Discord,
an einem Discord gab es nicht Teamspeak, ausgetauscht mit Leuten, vielleicht gab es irgendeinen
Forum, vielleicht hast du in-game einfach im World-Chat geschrieben, wenn du Content
machen wolltest, den du nicht allein machen konntest. Früher hast du gesagt, ok ich möchte
jetzt Dungeon XY machen und ich brauche noch einen Heiler, einen Tank und zwei Damage-Dealer
oder sowas in der Richtung. Das hast du dann im World-Chat gesagt, das hast du vielleicht
im jeweiligen Städte-Chat gesagt, das war egal ob das World of Warcraft war, Dark oder
sonst was, hast vielleicht im Guild-Chat gefragt, du hast deine Gruppe zusammengebaut, du hattest
später auch eine Freundesliste, wo du wusstest ok, der ist ganz guter Tank, der ist ganz
guter Support, was auch immer. Und dann kamen sie irgendwie auf die Idee, ok das dauert
ja zu lange. Die Leute sind ja quasi 40 Minuten damit beschäftigt, die Gruppe zusammen zu
suchen für einen stundenlangen Dungeon-Content. Und dann haben sie gesagt, ok wir machen einen
Dungeon-Finder, dass du quasi dich anmelden kannst, ich möchte Dungeon XY machen und
das Spiel matcht zusammen, so nach dem Motto, aha der spielt Tank, der spielt Support, der
spielt DD, matcht das so zusammen, dass eine gute Gruppe reinkommt, zusammen kommt und
dann wirst du auch noch in den Dungeon rein teleportiert. Also früher hast du die Leute
zusammen gesucht und bist zum Dungeon gelaufen, hast den Dungeon gemacht, hast Loot verteilt
und gut ist und es wurde alles automatisiert. Für Casual-Kacknoobs, die nie, die eigentlich
Singleplayer spielen wollen und in MMOs spielen ist das gut, ansonsten war das der Anfang
von Ende von guten MMOs. Weil der Haupt, eine der riesen Dinger, die MMOs ausmachen, ist
erstens die Server-Zugehörigkeit und eventuell die Realm-Zugehörigkeit, also sprich ich
bin Server XY, da kann sich wahrscheinlich jeder, der World of Warcraft gespielt hat
mit internifizieren, wie gesagt bei mir war es weniger, bei mir war es eben Dark Edge
of Camelot, aber du konntest dich in MMOs früher extrem damit internifizieren, ich
spiele auf Server XY im Reich sowieso, oder im Realm sowieso. Also die Leute haben dann
gesagt, sagt mir mal, keine Ahnung, was ist denn so ein World of Warcraft Server Name,
keine Ahnung, Malphurion, ich hab keine Ahnung ob es den Server gibt, ich spiele Malphurion
Horde und dann haben die Leute gesagt, jawoll geil ich auch und oah, bester Server und so,
die Zugehörigkeit aus Server und Realm, das war so eine Sache, die hat dich einfach ausgezeichnet,
das ist so wie wenn du sagst, Alter ich hab einen deutschen Pass oder, ich kann sagen,
das war Server plus Realm war einfach so Markenzeichen irgendwie. Und dementsprechend, du kanntest
auch die Leute auf dem Server. Du wusstest, was eine Spastengilde ist, du wusstest was
Flamekinners sind, du wusstest wer was taugt, du wusstest wen du gut spielen kanntest, so
du kanntest die Leute. So und das war das geile, das war das wichtigste an MMOs, sag
ich mal so neben dem normalen Content und das was Leute jahrzehntelang letztendlich in MMOs
hält, ist der soziale, der soziale, so Gilden und Zugehörigkeitsaspekt, der mittlerweile
komplett weg ist. Wie viele Leute haben, wenn sie quasi gerade nichts gemacht haben
in dem Game, das Spiel als Chat Sandbox verwendet? Ich kenn so viele Leute, die sind einfach
eingeloggt gewesen den ganzen Tag, nur um immer mal wieder rein zu gucken, was im Gildenchat
geschrieben wurde, immer mal rein zu gucken, ob irgendwie einer im Trade-Channel was schreibt,
immer mal zu gucken, gibts ein Forumspost oder irgendwie und sei es nur, brauch irgendwie
einer Hilfe aus meinem Reich, der, keine Ahnung, irgendwelchen Content nicht packt, was auch
immer. Das ist mit diesem Aspekt Dungeon Finder, das war der Anfang vom Ende von MMOs, von
dem Multi, von dem richtigen Multiplayer Aspekt von MMOs. Seitdem sind MMOs immer weiter Richtung
Singleplayer Content gegangen. So, gucken wir mal weiter. So, und der Typ, der hat es
mal in einem Interview hingestellt und gesagt, das wäre schlecht, so nach dem Motto. Der
hat sich hingestellt und gesagt, ja, die alten World of Warcraft Versionen so sinngemäß waren
kacke, die neuen haben Dungeon Finder. Warum hat so einer was zu sagen? Destiny, bin ich
nie so richtig reingekommen. Destiny, bin ich nie so richtig reingekommen. Oh je. Ach du.
Ja. Oh je. Das Hintergrottbild, please. Die konnten, die konnten aber gar nicht anders,
oder? Gitarro, ja.
Ich fand das so geil, als Chris Metzen noch selbst Voice Acting Sachen gemacht hat. Das
war immer so ein Zwischending aus, aus gut und schlecht. Was war das? Da kann ich mich
gar nicht mehr dran erinnern. Oh doch. Oh je, ja. Da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern.
Das war fail. Das war, oh man. Ja, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern. Das war die Geschichte,
wo sie gesagt haben, Nicknames sind böse. Wir sollen jetzt Klarnamen verwenden. So was
in der Richtung. Da kann ich mich doch, ja, da kann ich mich noch dran erinnern. Ja, und
letztendlich, letztendlich hat, muss man auch sagen, wie sie StarCraft 2 gehandelt haben,
hat das komplett zerstört. Also StarCraft ist nur noch ein Schatten seiner selbst mittlerweile.
Es ist ja nichts Neues, ne?
Und
Trolls. Oh ja, das ist eine fantastische Idee. Sie sind so witzig. Okay, aber wie
wechseln wir diesen toxischen Teil unserer Gemeinde ohne in ihrem Gesicht zu spüren?
Diese Entscheidung hatte natürlich die exakte Reaktion, die man erwartet hätte.
Die sind ausgeflippt, die sind ausgeflippt, die Leute.
Ich meine, wie bescheuert musst du sein und sagen so nach dem Motto, wer im Forum
postet Klar-Namen-Pflicht. Also was du damit quasi beschwörst,
ist erstens, dass die Leute keinen Bock drauf haben, was du damit, wenn Blizzard auch auf die
Idee kommen könnte, was du damit auslöst ist, die Leute machen es nicht und gehen einfach auf eine
andere Plattform. Da gehen die Leute halt nicht ins offizielle Forum, sondern flamen auf Reddit rum.
Ja, genau, genau. Das verstehe ich auch nicht. Ja.
Ja, da kann ich mich auch dran erinnern. Das war ein Riesen, das war ein Riesenaufschrei damals.
Ja, RealID ist halt die Frage, ist es RealID Pflicht oder kann man das machen? Ich glaube,
aktuell ist es so, man kann Freundesaccount upgraden und auswählen, ob man RealID sharen
will und solche Geschichten. Aber die wollten es ja machen, dass RealID Default ist, dass du da
nicht mal Eax heißt, sondern, ich weiß es gar nicht, Chris irgendwas. Und das ist halt Fail.
Das ist halt mega Fail, dass es Default mäßig sein soll. Black Ops 4 startet erstmal mit RealID.
Fail. Voll für den Arsch. RealID ist richtig kacke. Ich will nicht Max sonst wie heißen,
sondern ich will Informatikkorr heißen oder Wubblors oder sonst was. Ich will, dass nicht
mein Name dran steht. Das ist so unglaublich Fail. Ich meine, es ist im Einklang mit der
Entwicklung, wie sich das auch in der Politik so abspielt, so nach dem Motto, so eines der Sachen,
die sie ja schon gebetmäßig runterrattern mittlerweile über alles. Das Internet darf
kein rechtsfreier Raum sein. Übrigens habe ich euch schon mal gesagt, das Internet darf kein
rechtsfreier Raum sein. Facebook darf kein rechtsfreier Raum sein. Twitter darf kein rechtsfreier Raum sein.
Google darf kein rechtsfreier Raum sein. Sind sie ja auch nicht, egal wie oft man das sagt,
sind sie nicht. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Leute immer auf die Idee kommen, das sagen zu müssen.
Das ist kompletter Bullshit. Das Internet ist kein rechtsfreier Raum. Die Sachen gelten im
Internet genauso wie nicht im Internet. Also diese Sache immer so, dass es ein rechtsfreier Raum ist.
Totaler Schwachsinn ist es nicht. War es noch nie. Oder kennt ihr irgendein Gesetz, wo drinne steht,
das gilt nicht fürs Internet. Ja. Äh, Matic ist richtig. Also wenn die Leute in der heutigen Zeit,
du musst in der heutigen Zeit Angst haben, wenn du das falsche sagst und sei es, dass du dich einfach
nur schlecht, einfach nur nicht ganz der aktuellen Norm entsprechend ausdrückst. Da gibt es Leute,
die gucken nach, wer bist du, wo arbeitest du und rufen bei deinem Arbeitgeber an und sagen dem,
sie sollen dich rauswerfen, so nach dem Motto. Also so weit sind wir schon. Das heißt, es ist
zwingend erforderlich, dass die Leute sich überhaupt noch trauen, ihre Meinung auszusprechen,
dass es gewisses Maß an Anonymität im Internet gibt. Das klappt sonst gar nicht. Wir sind gerade
leider auf dem komplett entgegengesetzten Weg, dass wir alles, dass wir gerne Sachen verbieten
und dass wir gerne Diskussionen nicht haben wollen über unliebsame Themen. 2020, ja.
Wir sind gerade voll komplett in die andere Richtung unterwegs. Egal, wir gucken jetzt mal weiter.
Ja, richtig, genau das, was er sagt. Soweit sind wir ja heute schon. Wenn du dich im Internet
falsch ausdrückst, dann rufen irgendwelche Deppen bei deinem Arbeitgeber an und sagen,
hier ihr Mitarbeiter verbreitet was weiß ich rechten Hate Speech, unabhängig davon, ob du das
überhaupt gemacht hast oder nicht. Warum ziehen wir nicht alle nach Nordkorea? Das ist gut,
da kann man von Luftabwehrgeschützten erschossen werden, habe ich gehört.
Oh, Dota, Dota, genau.
Ich habe keine Ahnung von Dota, kein Plastenschimmer, aber eins muss ich sagen,
vor Icefrog ziehe ich echt meinen Hut. Ich kann da nicht so viel im Detail zu sagen,
weil ich weder Dota nicht spiele und auch nicht großartig Plan von habe, aber ich lese die ein oder
andere News zu Dota und ich lese auch ab und zu mal so ein bisschen Dota Reddit, einfach weil
es mich interessiert, was so passiert. Also vor Icefrog kann ich echt noch meinen Hut ziehen.
Zumindest das letzte Mal, wo ich geguckt habe, war der auch noch am Start. Also so lange an
einem Game zu arbeiten und vor allem es zu schaffen, dass das Game, was so viele Sachen
drin hat, balance technisch nicht komplett im Arsch ist. Also der schafft das mit Dota,
was Blizzard in ihren letzten Games nicht geschafft hat. Das Dota-Balancing, nach allem dem,
was ich gelesen habe, soll tatsächlich ganz gut sein. Also wohl eines der wenigen Games,
wo das Balancing wirklich ganz gut ist. Was wohl heißt, man kann mehr als eine Handvoll
Helden spielen. Und das muss er erstmal hinkriegen. Also Icefrog soll da wohl wirklich und es ist
selten, dass der Chef-Entwickler auf Reddit oder der Balance-Typ, dass die gelobt werden. Das ist
wirklich selten. Also wenn das offizielle Sub-Reddit zu was jemand lobt, da muss der die Sachen schon
extrem gut machen. Normalerweise wirst du geflamed, selbst wenn du die Sachen gut machst. So nach dem
Motto, warum machst du sie nicht noch besser? Reddit flamet halt einfach mal gerne. Aber wenn
du gelobt wirst auf Reddit, dann musst du die Sachen quasi so outstanding gut machen,
dass du gelobt wirst auf Reddit. Oder scheint er wohl zu machen. Also nicht so wie in Overwatch.
Ja genau, absolut nicht so. Overwatch-Balance im Arsch. StarCraft gucke ich gerade selten.
Teilweise auch ewig lange Patches, komplett im Arsch gewesen. Gut, wow, keine Ahnung von
ehrlich gesagt. Heroes habe ich auch keinen Plan mehr von. Bei Blizzard sind halt die Nerf-Ban
Geschichten legendär. Also sprich, wenn eine Fähigkeit ein bisschen zu stark ist, sagt Blizzard nicht,
okay wir passen jetzt die Fähigkeit an einer Stelle mal an und gucken was passiert. Oder aber
vielleicht wir buffen zwei, drei andere Fähigkeiten ein bisschen zum Ausgleich. Nein, Blizzard macht
immer diese kompletten, diese kompletten Benhammer-Dinger. So nach dem Motto, okay eine
Fähigkeit ist ein bisschen zu stark und jetzt nerven wir die nicht nur ein bisschen, sondern wir
machen die komplette Klasse useless, die diese Fähigkeit hat. Das ist so die Blizzard-Taktik,
die ich nie verstanden habe. Die schießen da teilweise total über das Ziel hinaus. So nach
dem Motto, okay irgendein Nahkampf-Angriff ist zu stark, das heißt wir machen jetzt die Range
geringer, wir machen den Damage geringer, wir machen Attack-Speed geringer, die Klasse kriegt
weniger Rüstung, weniger Mana-Regeneration, weniger Lebenspunkte, weniger Life-Rack, weniger
Resists und alle anderen Klassen buffen wir auch noch. So Patch fertig. Das ist so Blizzard-Patch.
Das machen sie bei Hearthstone auch sehr, Hearthstone-E-Sports-Lull. Egal, gucken wir mal
weiter. Das kann ich bis heute nicht verstehen, wie das so ausgehen konnte, wie es ausgegangen
ist, dass das wirklich, egal, gucken wir mal sehr zusammen. Das habe ich nie verstanden,
wie das so ausgehen konnte. Also die haben sich ja geeinigt, ohne dass es, das war irgendein
Vergleich und dass das Blizzard, dass das so ausgegangen ist, dass die Dota quasi mehr
oder weniger kampflos da abgegehen hat. Das kann ich bis heute nicht verstehen, wie das
so laufen konnte, wie es gelaufen ist. Da ist wahrscheinlich sehr viel Geld geflossen.
Ja, was muss da Geld fließen? Ich meine, es ist ja nicht so, als hätten beide Seiten
nicht genug Geld. Activision, Blizzard und wer? Was willst du da machen? Sollen die sich
gegenseitig mit Geldkoffern bewerfen? Die juckt das doch. Die haben doch beide genug
Kohle. Ja, choose my name. Genauso. Genauso. Das ist die Blizzard-Taktik.
Das stimmt. Und da hat Icefrog einen riesengroßen Anteil dran. Also wie gesagt, ich ziehe echt
meinen Hut vor Icefrog. Schaff kein Bild mit Hut. Ja.
Yep. Yep.
Warum eigentlich? Ich hab das nicht gespielt zum Damen, warum eigentlich? Ich fand's
ein bisschen lustig, dass jetzt Panda-Bären am Start sind, aber man darf nicht vergessen,
Panda-Bären gab's in Warcraft 3 sogar schon. Was fanden die Leute... Eax, hast du das nicht
gespielt? Was fanden die Leute damals eigentlich so schlecht an Mists of Pandaria? Viele mochten
das Setting nicht. Okay, das kann ich verstehen. Ich glaube, auch ein Punkt bei WoW, der dazu
gekommen ist. Guckt mal, das Game ist hier gestartet und hier war das die Hochzeit. Das
sind so ungefähr 6 Jahre. Man darf eine Sache nicht aus den Augen verlieren. Die Leute sind
mit dem Spiel aufgewachsen und irgendwann waren sie halt mal in einem gewissen Alter,
wo sie sich vielleicht auch für andere Sachen interessiert haben. Die meisten haben hier
so angefangen, hier haben noch ein paar dazugekommen und die Leute waren dann hier 13, 14, 15 und
hier waren sie 21, 22. Und die waren dann nicht mehr in der Schule, die haben auch nicht mal
studiert, die sind zum größten Teil an Arbeiten gegangen. Ich bin mir ziemlich sicher, dass
das auch ein Fall war, warum WoW ein bisschen runtergegangen ist. Natürlich kommt da auch
dazu, dass die Leute mit den Addons nicht zufrieden waren. Ich habe gesagt 13, 14, 15 und es sind
6 Jahre. Und 15 plus 6 sind 21. Quickmuffs.
Die haben auch einen Fehler gemacht. So als Außenstehender, der nie großartig WoW gespielt
hat. Die haben auch einen Fehler gemacht mit den Addons, die nach den ersten zwei gekommen
sind. Die haben einfach, die haben es sich einfach gemacht. Die haben gesagt, ok, neues
Addon bedeutet, neue Gebiet, neue Klasse, neues Itemlevel, neue Charakterlevel. Damit
machst du quasi 90% des Contents, der vorher da war, überflüssig. Das haben sie später
kapiert, dass das keine so gute Idee war, dass man ein Game hat, was zu 90%, 95% leer,
unbevölkert, sonst wie auch immer ist. Du hast ja in World of Warcraft mittlerweile
eine abartig große Landmasse, die keiner mehr braucht. Mittlerweile haben sie das ein bisschen
angepasst, du kannst Skins sammeln, Mounts sammeln, Achievements, was auch immer. Aber
ne, ich glaube, 500% nicht geschnallt haben sie es immer noch nicht. Das ist ein Problem,
mit dem viele MMOs kämpfen und viele Spiele mit Addons, dass umso mehr Addons kommen,
das alte immer irre unrelevanter wird. Da hätten die sich spätestens ab dem Zeitpunkt
etwas für einfallen lassen müssen, weil keiner will ein leeres Game haben. Und der
grundsätzliche Ansatz, dass World of Warcraft quasi so eine Raid-Gear-Spirale ist, so ein
bisschen wie Diablo eigentlich, bloß halt kriegt man Gier anders, macht es dann auch
nicht einfacher. Deswegen bin ich persönlich ja der Meinung, es hat noch keiner gemacht,
aber ich bin da an sich, es könnte funktionieren, ein MMO, was wieder auf mehr Community Aspekt
sitzt und was ein bisschen wie Path of Exile, weil Path of Exile macht das, was diese Währung
und wie nennt man das, diesen ganzen Geldfluss und Contentfluss eigentlich ganz gut. Also
du musst immer gucken, dass du Währung und Spielzeit irgendwie wieder rausnimmst, also
sprich, dass du Sachen hast, die verschwinden, aber in-Game-Zeit und Geld kosten, also mit
Geld meine ich in-Game-Währung oder Spielzeit. Also sprich, du musst irgendwie gucken, dass
es nicht immer mehr wird und das ist halt das Problem, was du in vielen Spielen hast,
am Anfang ist ein Gold viel, nach 10 Jahren Spiel ist ein Gold nichts, dann haben die
Leute dann irgendwie 50 Platinen, so viel wie ein Gold am Anfang. Das heißt, du musst
gucken, dass das Spielzeit, egal in welchem Teil von dem Spiel irgendwie Value hat, sei
es nur Low-Level-Crafting-Materialien sammeln, die mir für spezielle Sachen braucht oder
eben solche Dinge, wie gesagt, ich bin da kein Game-Designer in der Richtung, du musst
gucken, dass jeder Teil und jeder Aspekt von dem Spiel in irgendeiner Art und Weise Value
hat, für das Gesamtkonstrukt. Das ist nicht einfach, ich finde in Person of Exile haben
sie es ganz gut hingekriegt, so doof es klingt, sogar in BDO haben sie es irgendwie noch halbwegs
gut hingekriegt, in World of Warcraft gar nicht, da Gate of Camelot haben sie es eigentlich
auch ganz gut gemacht, dadurch, dass das halt ein halbwegs PvP-fokussiertes Spiel war und
das ist auch ein Punkt, wo ich denke, dass viele Spiele sich da mehr trauen sollten.
Es gibt auf der einen Seite so diesen Riesentrend hin zu, jeder muss so ein Battle Royale-Spiel
machen, oder eine Zeit lang jeder muss so einen Overwatch-Clone machen, aber im Umkehrschluss
guckt euch mal PvP oder Realm vs. Realm wie auch immer in den meisten MMOs an. Das ist
zum größten Teil absoluter Bullshit. Das ist entweder irgendwelche Arena-Kämpfe, die
keinerlei Auswirkungen auf das restliche Game haben, es sind irgendwelche komischen Duellgeschichten,
es ist fucking Capture the Flag und Domination in einem MMO, wirklich guter, spaßiger Timesync,
der auch Auswirkungen aufs Spiel hat, das trauen sich viel zu wenige MMOs.
Also zum Beispiel muss ich sagen, in Dark Age of Camelot war es so, das ist bei weitem
nicht das perfekte System, dass du indirekt belohnt wurdest, also du wurdest auf zwei
Sachen belohnt, wenn du viel PvP gemacht hast. Einmal, du hast halt unterschiedliche
Fähigkeiten gekriegt, klar, aber du konntest auch Relikte erobern, die dein komplettes
Reich quasi verstärkt haben. Also du konntest quasi Relikte erobern vom Gegner, da musstest
du quasi irgendeine Festung raiden beim Gegner im Grenzgebiet, musstest dort ein Relikt klauen
und bei dir in die Grenzfestung legen und dann hast du 10% mehr Nahkampfschaden, 10%
mehr Magieschaden. Das System war nicht perfekt, unter anderem aus dem Grund, weil ganz viele
Surfer extrem unbalanced waren, da haben dann 70% in einem Reich gespielt und es hatte
immer alle Relikte, das war auch für'n Arsch. Aber solche Systeme, das trauen sich viel
zu wenige MMOs. MMOs gehen lustigerweise immer mehr in Richtung Singleplayer, guckt euch
mal Elder Scrolls an, das ist ja wohl das perfekte Beispiel für'n Singleplayer MMO,
obwohl es ein richtig großes PvP-Gebiet hat, was glaube ich kaum einer wirklich großartig
verwendet. Das ist das Beispiel für Singleplayer MMOs und das trauen sich zu wenige. Und das
ist das womit du ein MMO glaube ich richtig nachhaltig machen könntest. Sodass jeder
Aspekt, und das ist auch das was ursprünglich mal den Erfolg von WoW ausgemacht hat, World
of Warcraft hatte mehr oder weniger für alle was dabei. Ja, von der Casual Hausfrau mit
5 Kindern, bis zum Hardcore No Sleep No Sonnenlicht 24 Sieben-Kreiner. Das ist das was, was World
of Warcraft am Anfang auch für alle so spannend gemacht hat. So, weiter. Muss mal kurz ein
bisschen zurückspringen, wir sind mal stehen geblieben. Ja, Jurok, das haben sie im Prinzip
immer noch, nur dass der soziale Aspekt heute und der für mich in MMO ausmacht nicht mehr
da ist. Ja. Das finden viele schlecht, ja. Ja. Ich habe mir ja sagen lassen, die Dungeon
Finder nennt man intern in WoW Looking for Retards. Stimmt das? Hat mir mal irgendjemand
erzählt. Ja. Jurok, das kann ich dir erklären. Er sagt, ich weiß nicht was so toll ist,
1,5 Stunden zu schreiben, die Idee für Mana Craft. Die eigentliche Sache 1,5 Stunden Leute
zu suchen ist nicht toll. Aber wenn du ein paar Mal 1,5 Stunden Leute gesucht hast, dann
kennst du die Leute auf deinem Server und du musst nicht mal 1,5 Stunden suchen, weil
du die Leute gefunden hast, die sich gut dafür eignen. Und vielleicht macht dir irgendwann
mal sogar eine Gilde auf mit allen Leuten, mit denen ihr regelmäßig zusammenspielt
oder geht zusammen in eine andere Gilde rein oder sonst was in der Richtung. Für die 0815
Low Level Dungeons ja, kann man sich darüber streiten, aber spätestens für normalen Content
fehlt einfach jeglicher soziale Aspekt. Das stimmt. Ne ne ne ne ne, das stimmt nicht,
das stimmt nicht. Also, er sagt, niemand zwingt einen das Tool zu verwenden. Doch. Doch, es
ist da. Das reicht schon. Niemand wird sich mehr hinsetzen und eine Gruppe im Chat zusammenbauen
wenn es ein Dungeon Finer Tool gibt. Wozu? Zumal es auch keiner sich daran beteiligen
wird und solche Gruppen noch reingehen und dann mit warten. Ne. Sobald es da ist, ist
der ursprüngliche soziale Aspekt von MMOs vorbei. Sobald es sowas gibt. Ich kenne aber
leider, also ich kann zu den Details, wie es letztendlich in World of Warcraft ist, nicht
viel sagen, weil ich hab das nicht großartig gespielt. Allerdings hat ja mittlerweile jedes
Game Dungeon Finder, ich hab ja mit dem Friseur Final Fantasy XIV gespielt, komplett durchgespielt
quasi inklusive Endgame. Und der Dungeon Finder führt einfach dazu, dass es ein instanziertes,
anonymes Kreisel-Kreiten ist. Also nicht das, was man bei einem MMO erwartet. Also zum Beispiel
in Final Fantasy XIV, da kann ich jetzt was von sagen, weil das hab ich gespielt zu World
of Warcraft, keine Ahnung, ist es so, du meldest dich an, sag mal für Daily Dungeon irgendwas,
meldest dich an, dann wirst du zusammengewürfelt mit Leuten, noch nicht mal von deinem Server
und die komplette Runde ist absolut anonym. Du joins rein, gogogobuff, es findet keiner
der Austausch zwischen den Leuten mehr statt, es wird einfach versucht quasi den Daily
Dungeon so schnell wie möglich runter zu reißen irgendwie und dann ist gut. Und gerade das
Zusammenwürfeln mit anderen Servern sorgt dafür, dass die Leute sich auch wirklich
aufführen wie die letzten Spasten, weil die Chance, dass du jemals anderes wieder mit
den gleichen Leuten in eine Gruppe kommst, ist verschwindend gering. Und das hat für
mich diesen Multiplayer Aspekt und auch gerade diesen sozialen MMO Aspekt komplett zerstört.
Das hat Numa World of Warcraft mit dem Dungeon Fighter die Wege geleitet und das hat seinen
Weg in alle anderen MMOs und fast alle anderen MMOs gefunden.
Oh je, Diablo 3, Auktionshaus.
Die Master Chief Collection auf dem PC hat immer nur noch drei Games, ne?
Vor allem, vor allem, am Anfang war das ja so, als das Game rausgekommen ist, du konntest
es nicht spielen. Du, du, du, also du musstest dich irgendwie 20 Stunden reinloggen so nach
dem Motto, bis es funktioniert hat, übertrieben. Aber du konntest schon mal so ein, zwei Stunden
versuchen dich einzuloggen, es hat nicht funktioniert.
Wie haben die Leute das damals auch, Bu-Babulo oder so, ne? Also das ist ja Diablo 1, Diablo
2 sah das ja mehr oder weniger so aus und in Diablo 3 hat er ja angeblich halt, boops,
glaube ich, Bu-Babulo haben sie immer gesagt. Und ja, ich finde auch, dass das gefährlicher
und mehr horrormäßig aussieht als das. Generell war in Diablo 3 einfach alles bunt
und familienfreundlich so nach dem Motto, ja.
Oh ja, da haben sie sich aufgeregt. Ja, ich weiß, dass es, ich weiß, dass es in der Story,
dass Diablo, in der Story von Diablo 3 eine Frau ist. Nichtsdestotrotz, man hätte das
ja nicht so machen müssen. Man hätte ja Diablo ohne Probleme so designen können, dass er
eben noch aussieht wie Diablo. Dass man dafür jetzt irgendwie eine fadenscheinige Story-Erklärung
hat, schön und gut, trotzdem hat man es von der Optik her verkackt. Vergleicht mal die
Optik von Diablo 1 und Diablo 2 mit der Optik von Diablo 3. Ja, Diablo 1, Diablo 2 sieht
zwar oldschool aus, aber es sieht nach Hölle, das nennen wir nach brutaler Hölle irgendwie
und Diablo 3 sieht nach World of Warcraft Hölle im Comic Look aus. Ja, Blizzard hat
schon teilweise bescheuerte Responses geliefert, ja. Aber es wird alles getoppt von den Antworten
für Fallout 76. Was dort als Antworten auf irgendwelche Fragen gekommen sind, wird keiner
mehr so schnell toppen. Da kann ich mich nicht mehr dran erinnern. Oh, ja.
Das war, das war, wie soll ich das beschreiben? Selbst ob man jetzt Diablo 3 mochte oder nicht,
das ist jetzt erstmal egal. Man hat sich gefragt damals, einfach nur, wie die auf die Idee
kommen konnten, sowas einzubauen. Man konnte akzeptieren, dass Diablo 3 vielleicht nicht
das Game war, was man sich gewünscht hatte, aber man hatte absolut kein Verständnis für
die Existenz dieses Auktionshauses mit Echtgeld. Man hat einfach nicht, man hat kein Verständnis
als Spieler dafür aufbringen konnten, wie Blizzard auf diese Idee kommen konnte. Man
natürlich aus Business-Sicht konnte das jeder nachvollziehen, so nach dem Motto, sie wollen
einfach Geld machen. Aber das ist ja nicht das, womit man Blizzard zumindest damals noch
verbunden hat. Man hat Blizzard nicht mit, wir sind EA Activision, was auch immer, Moneycrap
verbunden, sondern mit, wir sind eine Firma, die hauptsächlich eben gescheite Games macht,
mit denen man auch was verdienen kann, keine Frage, aber es war für die Leute nicht klar
und nicht nachvollziehbar, wie sowas es in das Game geschafft haben kann. Richtig, richtig.
Deswegen spiele ich in letzter Zeit auch gerne Pass of Exile. Es gibt in Pass of Exile auch
die Third-Party-Variante sich In-Game-Currency zu kaufen, da gehst du auf irgendeine China-Seite
und kaufst dir Chaos Orbs, Exile Orbs oder sonst was. Jenen tut das, du wirst höchstwahrscheinlich
auch nicht dafür gebannt, weil die das überhaupt nicht mitkriegen, aber es nimmt den Spaß aus
dem Game raus. Wozu sollte ich drei Tage grinden, einen Charakter verbessern und sonst was,
wenn ich mir einfach für 15 Dollar High-End Währung und High-End Gear kaufen kann und
dann in acht Stunden durchgerusht bin, bis Endgame komplett durch hab. Also es ist irgendwo
sinnlos. Ja, in Pass of Exile, klar, kommt noch die Sache dazu, dass es sich resettet
nach der Liga, aber du kannst ohne Probleme für Harvest, die Chinasachen sind sportbillig.
Ich muss ja sagen, ich hab damals auch, also nicht für Pass of Exile, aber ich hab, als
ich mit dem Fabian, ich glaub 2012, 2013, mal wieder ein bisschen in Dark Age of Camelot
reingeguckt hab, damals auf dem Ami-Server, da haben wir uns auch für glaub 15 Dollar
oder so In-Game Gold gekauft, bei so einer China-Seite. Davon haben wir komplett unseren
kompletten Charakter gegiert, inklusive alles, was man braucht, besser als die meisten Leute
hatten, die jahrelang gespielt haben. Einfach nur 15 oder 25 Dollar China-Seite.
Ja, und sie haben Diablo 3 komplett in Cellphone umgemodelt, was ich immer noch sehr merkwürdig
finde. Das Trading bzw. Trade-Channel-Gespamme war damals für mich, keine Ahnung, 2-3 Jahre
lang Daily-Business. Ich hab sogar damals Diablo 2 Sachen auf Ebay gekauft und verkauft.
So zu grauer Vorzeit. Legit, legit Windforce gesockelt. Eaglehorn 20 Euro, Mark, war das
noch Mark? Ich glaub noch Mark. Ja, am Anfang auf jeden Fall noch Mark, keine Dollar. Oder?
Wann kam Diablo 2? Moment, Moment, Moment. Ich glaub, nee, das müssen Euro gewesen sein.
Ja, ja, ja, es war ein Euro. Ja. Da war ich so 16 oder so in dem Dreh, da hab ich tatsächlich
ein bisschen Kohle gemacht mit Diablo 2 Items. Also mit Kohle gemacht, Kohle was man als
16-Jähriger im Jahr 2000 für Kohle hielte. Keine Ahnung, 50 Euro oder so ab und zu mal.
Jetzt nicht, ich bin damit nicht reich geworden. Ja. Dieses Dummgeschwätze, das hat er übrigens
nicht zu Diablo 3 gesagt, das hat er zu diesem Blitzchang Vorfall gesagt. By the way, Diablo
2 Ebay, muss ja eine Sache zu erzählen. Was damals richtig big brain war, also wo man
easy, easiest money überhaupt machen konnte, war, man hat sich auf Ebay einen großen Pack
Währung gekauft, das war meistens Stone of Jordan in Diablo 2, das war so eine Ring.
Man hat sich in großer Anzahl von Währungen auf Ebay gekauft und manchmal konnte man sogar
mit den Verkäufern ein bisschen verhandeln, so nach dem Motto, hey, ich kauf dir noch 20
mehr ab, das ist ein bisschen billiger. Man hat sich, keine Ahnung, 100 Stück gekauft,
was dann relativ billig pro Stück preis war. Dann ist man in Trade Channel und hat sich
begehrte Items gekauft und diese Items hat man dann auf Ebay wieder verkauft. Das war
im Prinzip keinerlei Game Aufwand, du musstest einfach nur Ebay Währung kaufen, bist du
in den Trade Channel gegangen und hast beliebte Items gekauft, weil die Noobs, die Casuals
für Diablo 2 damals, die hatten da keine Ahnung von, die wollten einfach nur ein spezielles
Item für ihren Charakter, das da gut war und die haben auf Ebay dann das Item gekauft.
Und das war richtig easy mode im Endeffekt, hätte ich damals schon programmieren können,
wenn ich das versuche, bestimmt zu botten. Irgendwie. Das war nice schon, das war richtig,
das war schon richtig cool, dass das funktioniert hat. Ja, das hat man sich damals echt gefragt,
vor allem mit dem Auktionshaus, hat man sich echt gefragt, wie kommt denn, oh nein, Ostarios,
ich habe dort mehr World of Warcraft Classic gespielt als die World of Warcraft Vanilla
Zeiten. Ich habe tatsächlich einige, einige Stunden, Tage drinne versenkt in Ostarios.
Ja. Der Server war richtig gut, der Server war
richtig gut und auch so krass bevölkert, habe ich in wenigen MMOs gesehen. Du bist da reingekommen
und wenn du als Ork bist du ja, ich weiß nicht wie das heißt, in irgendein Wüstending gespawnt,
da waren 500 Leute um dich drum herum, das war wirklich wie bei Release, du hast keine
Noobs gefunden, die mussten irgendwann auf dem Server die Sichtweite runterstellen, dass
du die Mops erst gesehen hast, wenn du in sie reingelaufen bist. Also das war cool, das war
richtig nice. So und Blizzard hat sich jetzt gedacht, fuck you, wir machen euch dicht.
Ja, da haben die sich so viel Hass zugezogen.
Die müssen, ob die die down nehmen müssen, dass sie sonst ihr Copyright verlieren ist
fraglich. Man hätte ja auch irgendeinen Deal machen können mit Nostalrius.
Es wäre auf jeden Fall, es hätte auf jeden Fall andere Optionen gegeben, als den Server
einfach down zu nehmen und da haben die sich extrem viel Hass zugezogen. Und danach kam
das Interview, jetzt kommt, danach oder ungefähr zur gleichen Zeit kam das Interview mit dem
Typ, wo ich freund gesagt habe, den kann ich nicht mehr sehen, der wirklich in dem Interview
gesagt hat, dass die Leute eigentlich Classic nicht spielen wollen.
Das ist sogar das Interview, was ich meine, ich hoffe, ich hoffe, das kommt noch.
Ja, das meine ich, das meine ich. Das geht noch weiter. Was ein Depp, die Leute haben
800.000 Accounts angelegt.
Es ist so fail, das geht mir nämlich bei Blizzard mittlerweile auch auf den Sack und bei vielen
anderen Herstall, dass die mittlerweile so krass überheblich sind, so nach dem Motto
ok, ok, ich gebe zu, man kann nicht auf jeden Scheiß hören, den die Community sagt. Das
ist ja auch keine demokratische Abstimmung, so eine Spieleentwicklung. Man kann auch nicht
auf jeden Furz hören, dem einer auf Reddit quer im Bauch sitzt. Das ist schon klar,
das geht nicht. Aber dass die so überheblich an vielen Stellen mittlerweile sind, so nach
dem Motto, die Spieler können gar nicht wissen, was ihnen besser gefallen würde.
Die Classic-Server spielen relativ viele Leute. World of Warcraft Classic spielen ziemlich
viele Leute. Wobei ich ganz ehrlich sagen muss, mir ist ein privat betriebener World
of Warcraft Classic-Server fast lieber als ein offizieller von Blizzard, weil wir mittlerweile
wissen, dass Blizzard einen Scheiß drauf gibt und fast alle anderen Hersteller einen
Scheiß drauf gibt, was die Leute sich für das Game wünschen. Ganz im Gegensatz zu einem
privaten Serverbetreiber. Je nachdem, da kannst du auch Spasten erwischen. Und mittlerweile
sind alle so extrem überheblich geworden, so nach dem Motto, es können noch so viele,
es können 50.000 Spieler sagen, so nach dem Motto, das und das gefällt uns nicht. Wir
machen es dann gerade, weil wir das für richtig halten, wir wissen, was gut für die Leute
ist. Das sind viele Hersteller so extrem überheblich geworden. Es gibt Gegenbeispiele, wie gesagt,
ich finde, die Jungs bei Pass und Wegsein machen das ziemlich gut. Da ist auch viel
Geflame auf Reddit. Aber im Großen und Ganzen, finde ich, machen die das eigentlich ganz
gut, wenn man sich überlegt. Das spiele ich von 2013 und mittlerweile fast größer
wie je zuvor. Zum Teil, wenn man mal was Shootermäßiges nehmen will, zum Teil Rainbow Six soll wohl
auch ein paar Sachen machen, die die Community gerne haben will. DICE in der Vergangenheit
hat bei Battlefield auch ab und zu mal auf die Leute gehört. Also es gibt schon auch
noch ein paar Gegenbeispiele. Aber mittlerweile sind viele so extrem überheblich und das
sieht man auch an Spielen wie beispielsweise Anthem. Spiele wie Anthem werden nur gemacht,
weil man einfach extrem überheblich ist, weil man denkt, man weiß es einfach besser.
Obwohl man ja eigentlich davon ausgehen muss, gerade in solchen Business-Sachen, wo so
viel Geld drin steckt, da wird auch mal ordentlich analysiert. Aber was man bei Anthem gesehen
hat, ist wohl auch nicht allzu gründlich. Ja, genau, Medics, das kommt dazu. Der Chef
von Crying In Gear Games, also das sind die, die Pass und Wegsein machen, der ist manchmal
auf Twitch in Livestreams und lässt sich vom Chat befragen, wo gibt es denn sonst sowas
und erklärt dann auch Sachen. Und du kannst den Pass so wechseln, wenn du viel Kohle
hast, sogar Items designen. Ja, aber da brauchst du schon sehr viel Kohle zum Fenster rausschmeißen
wollen. Also es gibt durchaus noch Hersteller, die das machen, aber gerade die Co's, die
sind mittlerweile so extrem überheblich, dass ich mir fast schon Gedanken machen würde,
wirklich viel Zeit in Spiele dort zu investieren, weil die jederzeit, wenn ihnen der Furz quer
sitzt, quasi irgendwas anderes draus machen können. Ja, das ist so, Felix Spitzer, deswegen
sage ich ja, du darfst nicht auf jeden Mist hören, den Leute da auf Reddit rumheulen
oder so. Aber wenn es 50.000 Posts zu irgendwas gibt, dann sollte man sich vielleicht mal
zumindest Gedanken machen, ob da was dran ist. Das heißt nicht, dass man es letztendlich
macht, aber wenn man selbst der Meinung ist, man genommen ist irgendwie Super Stonks Manager
bei irgendeinem Spieleentwickler und sagt, okay, dieser Charakter, der muss auf, was
weiß ich, wir wollen diese und diese Spielmechanik auf jeden Fall so lassen. So und wenn es dann
50.000 Posts gibt, wo die Leute sagen, macht das, was weiß ich, unser Vorschlag ist, macht
es lieber so und so, dann sollte man zumindest mal auf die Idee kommen, sich da Gedanken
darüber zu machen, okay, ist da vielleicht was dran? Max, spielst du WoW? Ne, spiele
nicht. Ich habe ein bisschen auf Nostalrius gespielt, da geht es gerade rum, ganz kleines
bisschen. Aber es sind viele Spielentwickler so extrem überheblich geworden in der Richtung
mittlerweile, dass die gar nicht dran hängen. Guckt euch mal an, wie lange StarCraft 2 gebraucht
hat in der Vergangenheit, ich weiß nicht, wie es aktuell ist, ich verfolge das nicht
mal so, bis dort Sachen sinnvoll gepatcht wurden und Mechaniken, guck mal, ich kann
mich noch dran erinnern, das war auch die Zeit, wo ich aufgehört habe, StarCraft 2
zu gucken und es war auch die Zeit, wo viele Leute aufgehört haben, StarCraft, also viele
Pros StarCraft 2 zu spielen. Es war die Zeit, glaube ich, beim zweiten Addon, wo diese
ganze, wie hieß das, Swarm, Prutes, wie hieß das, diese Einheiten, die unendlich Einheiten
spawnen können, Prude Host, ne, Swarm Host, Swarm Host, Swarm Host, als Swarm Host Meta
angesagt war. Das war erstens mega scheiße zu gucken, es hat Pro-Gamer abgefuckt ohne
Ende, es haben viele aufgehört und das hat wie lange gedauert, ein halbes Jahr, bis Blizzard
überhaupt mal eingestanden hat, dass da irgendwas nicht stimmt, Blizzard hat die ganze, ach
nö nö, das ist schon gut so, ja dann, learn to play, hohohoho, ja, scheiße war es, ja
und das ist für'n Arsch. Gut, wollen wir mal weiter. Und mittlerweile haben's ja viele
Hersteller gecheckt, zumindest, dass man nicht mehr ein halbes Jahr braucht, bis ein Patch
rauskommt, sondern dass man heutzutage, Fortnite macht's vor, ohne Scheiß, ich spiel
kein Fortnite, ich bin auch kein großer Fortnite Fan, Fortnite macht's vor, die machen viele
Patches, schnelle Patches und reagieren auf aktuelle Sachen. Wenn du heute in Fortnite
logst, kannst du nicht mal sicher sein, dass das, dass es sich noch so spielt wie gestern
quasi. Na, ist übertrieben gesagt. So musst du's machen. Ups, fuck, muss ich mal stehengeblieben.
Ja. No. And by the way, you don't want to do that either. Ja, den guck ich mittlerweile
auch echt gern, ja. So, am besten aber irgendwie als Zusammenfassung, weil ich spieler kein
World of Warcraft. Ja, richtig. Monarch S. Ja, es ist ja immer mal so, dass man, wenn
du sowas machst, was es in viktig ist. Aber selbst wenn du was compassierst, resiliency
Einen Monat irgendwas zu fixen.
Ja, ja.
Jetzt, jetzt kommt's. Das kenn ich.
Dungeon Finder! Der Depp, Alter!
Dungeon Finder! Das Schlimmste, was einem im OSJ passiert ist, feiert er voll ab.
Die hätten geboot werden müssen. Na ja, Medics, gebe ich dir recht, aber man darf nicht vergessen,
die Leute, die da hingefahren sind, sind Hardcore Blizzard-Fans und außerdem haben die Geld für den Eintritt bezahlt. Also, also, wenn du da jetzt nicht hinstellst und boosts,
dann stellst du nicht nur, dann stellst du komplett in Frage, was machst du überhaupt da?
Die wollen es nicht wahrhaben.
Haben sie nicht. Haben sie nicht.
Hätten sie nämlich die Nostalius-Devs dabei genommen, dann hättest du auf jeden Fall noch welche gehabt, die auch Interesse hatten, da quasi das aktiv zu supporten und auch
was dran zu machen noch.
Wer ist dieser Typ? Das ist ein Dwarf. Und, äh, weißt du was, ich mag ein kleiner Mensch.
Na ja, okay.
Nicht viele Entwickler haben eine ganze Konvention an ihrer Disposal und es ist nur Blizzards Weg, ihre Macht zu zeigen, Fans gehypt zu konsumieren.
Aber im Jahr 2018, BlizzCon wurde das Gegenteil davon.
Hear ye, hear ye, fans of Diablo. Behold, the new experience you've been waiting for. Diablo, for immortal.
Der Ubisoft-Stream ist, glaub ich, heute um 8 oder um 21 Uhr. Ich bin mir noch nicht sicher, ob ich das streame.
Äh, Diablo Immortal. Wie sieht's da eigentlich gerade aus mit?
Da hat sich nicht so viel getan, würd ich sagen.
Diablo Immortal Update.
Hoppla, juckt keinen.
Guckt euch die Dislikes an.
Was, es gibt dann Watch Dogs 2 kostenlos? Ja, Watch Dogs 2 ist ja auch der Sack. Alter.
Monarch S-Hands heute. Wo sind wir stehen geblieben?
Hier warten wir ungefähr.
Hear ye, hear ye, fans of Diablo. Behold, the new experience you've been waiting for. Diablo, for immortal.
Habt ihr's gehört? Habt ihr's gehört? Die, ähm, die Vorklatscher, Vorjubler haben gesagt, yeah, yeah, yeah. Und es hat keiner mitgemacht.
Oh, ey, das war so cringe. Die haben mir Leid getan auf der Bühne. Aber was man daran auch gesehen hat, ist, die sind komplett, aber komplett abgehoben, so detached, losgelöst von dem, was die Leute eigentlich erwartet haben.
Wie konnte man das nicht kommen sehen?
Abgehoben, genau.
Peck, warte.
Genau, das war der beste, das war einfach der beste.
Das kannst du mir immer wieder anhören.
In Wirklichkeit denkt man sich, Alter, du Spaßstor, warum hast du so eine kacke Frage gestellt?
Was?
Genau.
Die haben doch alle einen Rhetorikkurs vorher gemacht, oder? Wie bringe ich Hype vor einem Publikum rüber? Weil ansonsten, mach ich mal.
Ansonsten, ansonsten machst du noch nicht solche Dinge auf der Bühne. Da musst du den Rhetorikkurs gemacht haben vorher. Sonst kommst du noch nicht auf so eine Idee, oder? Also, wer macht das?
Ja, stimmt, das machen wir noch.
Was, dieses Jahr gibt es keine BlizzCon? Ja, ist ja auch nicht schlimm, weil letztes Jahr die BlizzCon war mega ResidentSleeper.
Pater Ohherli, fünf Monate, dankeschön. Exzellent Subscription, BigBrainSub.
Ich fand Diablo 4 auch mega langweilig. Das war so nach dem Motto, oh fuck, wir müssen jetzt irgendwas machen. Scheiße, was machen wir? Diablo 4.
Und wenn, also wenn die nicht jetzt was komplett, komplett neuen, nahezu revolutionären, wie auch immer Ansatz finden, sehe ich Diablo 4 nicht bestehen gegen Path of Exile 2. Oder gegen Path of Exile an sich. Das ist einfach das schlicht und ergreifend bessere Game. Path of Exile ist das Diablo 2, was Leute als Diablo 3 hatten haben wollten.
Oh ja. Ja, den gibt es ja auch leider nicht mehr.
Path of Exile hat eine Mobile Ankündigung. Ja, die war richtig gut, die Mobile Ankündigung. Die haben sogar noch Diablo ein bisschen verarscht dabei.
Also das muss man Nintendo echt mal, also auch Iwata da echt hoch anrechnen. Der hat damals gesagt, bevor ich Leute rausschmeiße, nehme ich lieber weniger Geld. Okay. Aber das kann man natürlich jetzt von Blizzard oder nicht, von Activation Blizzard oder von EA oder so natürlich nicht erwarten.
Das kann man, das kann man auch wirklich von denen nicht erwarten. Weil die, sagen wir mal so, die Ziele sind da auch komplett, komplett anders irgendwie. Also die haben Ziele definiert und Leute hingesetzt, die diese Ziele umsetzen sollen.
Das ist voll, das ist komplett undenkbar bei EA sowas zu machen. Das ist nicht im, wie sagt man so schön, nicht im Scope.
Oh, da stehen schon Zähne. Im Scope, genau.
Das Timing, das Timing war aber schon ein bisschen unglücklich für Blizzard. Quasi dort, in dem Jahr, wo man das meiste Geld ever gemacht hat, auch die meisten Leute dazu kicken.
Sind es nicht die? Sind es nicht die, die Torchlight gemacht haben später?
Oh nein, das. Da haben sie sich auch so tief in die Kacke gesetzt.
Okay, ich lasse ihn jetzt erstmal erzählen, dann muss ich auch mal einen Senf dazu ablassen.
Freidum!
Ja, man kann ja, sagen wir so, man kann ja in China nichts auf den Markt bringen selber, sondern man braucht immer eine chinesische Firma, die das für einen macht.
Also ich kann jetzt nicht sagen, hallo ich bin der Max, ich, keine Ahnung, ich stelle Computermäuse her und ich verkaufe die jetzt in China. So einfach ist das in China nicht. Du brauchst eine chinesische Firma, die die dort für dich verkauft.
Genau, ich stelle Keck WSS Service her. Ich will die Software da verkaufen.
Ja, also.
Ja, also da muss ich jetzt, ich hab mich damals auch schon so, aber da muss ich jetzt erstmal was zu sagen.
Es ist absoluter Bullshit, wie der ganze Fall gelaufen ist. Man darf nicht vergessen, ein Funken Verständnis für Blizzard kann ich in einer Richtung aufbringen.
Und zwar, dass sie es natürlich doof finden, wenn jemand in einem ihrer offiziellen Streams Statements macht, die ihnen nicht in die Geschäftsstrategie passen. Das kann ich verstehen, dass das Blizzard an sich ein bisschen doof findet.
Wer würde es nicht doof finden, wenn einer quasi in etwas, was ich bereitstelle, Dinge erzählt, die nicht in meine Strategie passen. Aber, wie sie das gehandhabt haben, ist unter aller Sau gewesen. Und es zeigt auch mal wieder, dass es einzig und allein darum geht, Geld zu verdienen.
Die haben nicht nur, dass sie den Typ gebannt haben, für, ich weiß gar nicht, übertrieben lange Zeit, ich glaube zwei Jahre oder so. Die haben sein Preisgeld einbehalten, die haben sein Preisgeld rückwirkend, was irgendwie noch nicht ausgezahlt war, einbehalten.
Die haben die Caster gebannt. Müsste ich mal vorstellen, die Caster, die damit nichts zu tun hatten, die einfach nur im Livestream das Spiel gecastet haben und das Interview geführt haben und sich versteckt haben vor der Kamera, die haben die Caster gefeuert.
So. Und das war alles so ein riesen Bullshit, wahnsinnig überzogen und wo man sieht, es ist komplett, es ist komplett Heuchelei, dass so eine Firma jetzt irgendwelche Black Life Matter Statement macht.
Es geht überhaupt nicht drum, ob man für Menschenrechte in Hongkong ist, ob man für Black Lives Matter ist oder irgendwas oder dafür, dagegen, sonst was. Man kann den ganzen Unternehmen, die auf dieser Welle, auf diese Welle aufspringen, man kann es nicht ernst nehmen.
Es ist pure, es ist pure Heuchelei in dem Fall. Es ist ein reiner PR-Move. Ja. Und gerade eine Firma, wie sei es, es haben ja alle, von EA bis Ubisoft bis Activision bis, es haben ja alle Black Life Matter Statements rausgehauen.
Wie passt das zusammen, dass man vorher quasi auf jemand, der sich für Menschenrechte in Hongkong einsetzt, so drauf scheißt, rein aus Geldgründen und dass man dann möchte, dass man sich da quasi solidarisch zeigen und PR-Move machen, was Black Life Matters angeht.
Das widerspricht sich einfach komplett. Zumal man auch sagen muss, das Activision Blizzard, wäre es erlaubt, die haben da, denen geht es weder um Menschenrechte in Hongkong, denen geht es weder um Black Life Matters, denen geht es um nichts anderes außer sich selbst.
Und wenn die dürften, wenn die dürften, und das ist ja die Bedingungen unter den Programmierer der Arbeiten, ist wahrscheinlich auch nicht allzu toll in vielen Stellen. Wenn die dürften, würden die sich morgen irgendwelche Sklaven in den Keller setzen, der für sie Spiele programmiert.
Da hätten die keine Probleme. Wäre es legal, Programmier-Sklaven im Keller zu halten, die würden das machen. Das wäre denen vollkommen egal. Gut, es ist nicht erlaubt, deswegen machen sie es nicht. Das ist denen alles scheißegal.
Solange das erlaubt ist und solange das image-mäßig gut aussieht. Deswegen sind die ganzen Statements, die dort rausgehauen würden, vollkommene Heuchelei und vollkommen einzig und allein PR-Move. Ich kaufe das kaum einer Firma ab, dass die da wirklich ernsthaft dahinterstehen.
Das liest sich so, als gäbe es irgendwo einen Black Life Matters Statement Generator und dort gibt man seinen Firmennamen ein und kriegt ein Statement raus, was man dann auf Twitter und Facebook posten kann.
Das ist einfach nur PR-Move, sonst nichts. Und gerade bei Blizzard ist es doppel lächerlich, wenn man vorher einen Hearthstone-Spieler so krass bestraft und ein paar Monate später so ein Statement raus hat.
Wer soll das glauben? Das glaubt niemand, der das mitbekommen hat, was davor passiert ist. Das ist einzig und allein der Versuch, sich ein bisschen in der Öffentlichkeit zu sonnen und als gute Menschen darzustellen oder als tolle Firma darzustellen, die man nicht ist. Guckt mal weiter.
2-0-W
Die fucking Caster wurden gebannt. Die waren einfach nur im Bild.
Guck mal, die haben sich versteckt. Die Caster wussten genau, was ist.
Vor allem, wenn man vorher noch eine offizielle Sache rausgehauen hat, wir wollen auf unseren Plattformen keine politischen Statements. Ja, was ist denn das denn sonst, wenn kein politisches Statement, was sie dann ein paar Wochen später selbst rausgehauen haben?
Ja, aber was interessiert uns denn die Bürgerrechte in Hongkong? Die sollen gefälligst unseren Scheiß kaufen. Was für Scheiß auf Bürgerrechte, das ist denen doch egal. Wo man sieht, ist es einfach pures sich versuchen gut dastehen zu lassen.
Ihr müsst euch mal überlegen, wie das in Hongkong gerade ist. Es gibt Leute in Hongkong, die im Ausland, sagen wir mal, studieren oder sonst was, die sich jetzt schon darauf einstellen, sie werden nie wieder in ihre Heimat zurückkehren.
Die sagen, okay, mit den Änderungen, die da jetzt eingeführt wurden, es gibt glaube ich ab 21. Juli oder so, gibt es irgendeine Gesetzesänderung in Hongkong, dass Hongkong quasi mehr oder weniger komplett, dass die chinesische Regierung jetzt quasi komplett das Sagen hat.
Also sprich, du kannst ohne Verfahren, wenn es um staatliche Angelegenheit geht, in Knast kommen und solche Geschichten. Und es gibt Leute, die sind halt, die hauen entweder ab aus Hongkong, sie überlegen sich jetzt sogar schon Ausgangssperren irgendwie zu verhindern.
Und es gibt Leute, die sind jetzt in Hongkong, studieren vielleicht im Ausland oder sonst was und die stellen sich ernsthaft darauf ein gerade, sie sind die letzten paar Wochen in ihrer Heimat und sehen sie danach nie wieder.
Und das sind Entwicklungen in Hongkong, die sind auch heftig, aber meinst du das, sag mal irgendeiner irgendwas zu, das ist, das ist vollkommen, geht vollkommen am Arsch vorbei.
So und dazu kommt noch, wisst ihr, wer die einzigen zwei Länder sind oder einer der wenigen Länder, die einen Einwanderungsprogramm gestartet haben für Hongkong?
Also sprich, es gibt in England und den USA, ich glaube die USA, also England einmal, also UK, man muss ja sagen, der Gram hat ja mal mehr oder weniger zum UK, war ja geliehen an England.
Und ich glaube die USA, UK und USA vielleicht noch ein, zwei andere Länder, ich weiß nicht genau, das sind lustigerweise die Länder, wo wir gerade hier überall am Haten sind, so nach dem Motto, wie schlimm es da ist und wie schlimm da die Regierung ist und sonst was.
Man muss da kein großer Fan von sein, aber dass gerade diese Länder, die wir ja angeblich so auslachen gerade, dass die quasi den Mut dazu haben einen Einwanderungsprogramm für Hongkong bereitstellen, passt irgendwie nicht ins aktuelle Weltbild.
Und ganz ehrlich, ich hätte überhaupt keine Probleme damit. Warum musst du da zweimal, warum musst du da zweimal überlegen? Guckt mal, es gibt zum Beispiel, ich hab nur einen Artikel gelesen, ich hab nur einen Artikel gelesen von jemand, der kommt aus Hongkong, der studiert in Deutschland, ist im September, geht sein Studium weiter, ist gerade in Hongkong und er sagt gerade, er ist gerade mehr oder weniger dabei, sich von allen Leuten zu verabschieden, weil er davon ausgeht, er wird seine Heimat nie wieder sehen.
So, und er würde gerne in Deutschland bleiben, ist aber schwierig. Warum müssen wir da ernsthaft dreimal überlegen, ob wir jemand, der aus Hongkong kommt, dort aus Menschenrechtsgründen nicht mehr hin kann, in Deutschland studiert hat, warum überlegen wir da dreimal, ob der hier bleiben darf?
Ich mein, wegen mir kann der sofort hier bleiben, ist doch super. Das ist ein Einwand, der kann Deutsch, der hat studiert, der wird auf jeden Fall auch wirtschaftlich was bringen, das ist super, warum sollte man sich das dreimal überlegen? Der könnte meinetwegen sofort hier bleiben, aber wir wollen nicht. Wir sagen, nein, da fangen wir es gar nicht mit an.
Wahrscheinlich sind wir zu, vielleicht haben wir zu viel Schiss vor China, ich weiß es nicht.
Die USA ist eines der Länder, die ein Einwanderungsprogramm hat für Hongkong. Wir denken an sowas anscheinend nicht. Und warum nicht? Ich mein, was kann uns besseres passieren, als jemand, der quasi schon, also der aus Hongkong kommt, in Deutschland studiert, den viel besseren Integrierten wirst du nicht finden.
Warum müssen wir da zweimal überlegen, ob wir den nehmen?
Sofort? Sofort?
Also wenn ich die Auswahl hätte, zum Glück, zum Glück muss ich das nicht entscheiden, und sicherlich ist das moralisch auch fragwürdig, aber nur ich persönlich. Also wenn ich die Auswahl hätte, nehme ich Leute, die in Deutschland studieren und aus Hongkong kommen auf, oder nehme ich einen von da, wo man teilweise Videos sieht, wo randaliert wird an der Grenze auf, ich persönlich tendiere eher zum Hongkong-Flüchtling.
Aber wie gesagt, das ist moralisch fragwürdig, ob man das überhaupt so entscheiden kann. Ich verstehe aber nicht, warum man da überhaupt lange überlegt. Ich würde den aus Hongkong sofort aufnehmen, wenn er will.
Aber da haben wir keinen Bock drauf.
Naja, wie dem auch sei, Menschenrechte wichtig, allerdings Menschenrechte in China ist uns egal.
So, weiter.
Achja, wir schreien lieber rum, wenn Polizisten auf Leute schießen, die mit dem Messer auf sie zurennen. Das ist ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz schlimm. Da reden wir uns super auf.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das mitgekriegt habt.
Vor ein paar Wochen wurde ein Typ mit einem riesen Messer auf einen Polizist zugestürmt, und der Polizist hat ihm noch ins Bein geschossen, wo sich dann alle drüber aufgegegt haben.
Das war bestimmt rassistisch motiviert. Der Typ ist mit dem fucking Messer auf ihn zu gerannt. What the fuck?
Was soll er dann machen?
Ich verstehe es nicht. Ich muss mal meine Klimaanlage anmachen. Ist übelst, übelst warm.
Die Frage ist grundsätzlich falsch. Ich weiß gar nicht welche.
Warm? Ja, es ist übelst warm. 25 Grad.
So, wir gucken jetzt erstmal das Video fertig.
Ja, ja.
Echt? Echt? Das hab ich gar nicht mitgekriegt.
Ja, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment, Moment.
Das hat Blizzard gemacht.
Nachdem der Aufschrei so lang, so extrem war, Blizzard hat erstmal gedacht, sie können das Ganze aussetzen.
Er aussetzten.
Er hat nichts gesagt. Er hat nichts gesagt.
Also die Ansprache am Anfang der Blizzcon von ihm war einfach nur leere Worthülsen aneinander gereiht.
Ja, oh fuck, jetzt kommt Freeforged. Oder auch genannt Deforged.
Refunded.
Ja, das ist auch so. Es ist so fail, man darf nicht vergessen.
Die haben das rausgebracht und im gleichen Zuge den alten Client abgeschafft.
Also sprich, Features die es gegeben hat waren von heute auf morgen weg.
Was denkt man sich dabei, dass sie Highstandards haben?
Wobei, wobei, hey, The Last of Us 2 ist da auch ganz gut dabei.
Moment, da muss ich mal gucken was schlechter ist.
Nicht Reforged, PS4, egal ob es PS4 ist.
Das ist doch gar nicht mal so schlecht jetzt.
Das geht ja sogar, das wurde teilweise, am Anfang war das so richtig schlecht.
Das geht sogar bei 5, 5 geht halbwegs. Aber Deforged, also Reforged ist immer noch Deforged oder Refunded je nachdem.
Also 0.6 musste er erst mal schaffen.
Und das schafft man auch nur, wenn man eine gewisse Fanbase hat.
Also sprich, kein Spiel was einfach rauskommt und schlecht ist.
Einfach das schlechteste Spiel der Welt, wenn das jetzt erscheint, wird nicht so einen schlechten Score bekommen.
Das schaffst du nur, wenn du eine Fanbase hast, Erwartungen schürst und die gnadenlos enttäuscht.
Nur dann schaffst du sowas.
Ah ja, by the way, weil ich es gerade im Chat sehe, ich hab letztens auch einen Artikel drüber gelesen,
dass wenn wir uns hier drüber beschweren, dass viele unsere Technikgeräte quasi in China unter unmenschlichen Bedingungen hergestellt werden,
dass es mittlerweile so ist, dass viele Chinesen, dass es denen auch besser geht jetzt,
dass die gar keinen Bock mehr haben unter den aller unmenschlichsten Bedingungen zu arbeiten
und dass die jetzt die Nordkoreaner dafür nehmen, den ganz schlimmsten Bodensatz an Jobs zu machen.
Also sprich, das wo sich jetzt sogar die Chinesen zu fein für sind, das dürfen dann die Nordkoreaner machen.
Also es wird immer an denen, dem es noch schlechter geht, durchgereicht.
Ja, das stand bis zum Release-Tag, stand das auf der offiziellen Webseite.
Guck mal, die hatten sogar mehr Animation und Kamera als im Original, äh, als Remastered. Das ist schon geil, oder?
Ja, deswegen spielen die ganzen Pros auch nicht mit dem Remastered, ähm, die ganzen Pros spielen nicht mit Remastered,
weil du die Einheiten nicht mehr richtig erkennst.
Ja, dass sowas nicht drin ist, kann ich nicht nachvollziehen.
Es gab ja ein paar Show-Matches zum Release und die Show-Matches sind irgendwie 5-6 Mal abgeschissen.
Man hat das richtig gesehen, die Pros, die sind teilweise übelst abgeraget, wie scheiße das Game ist.
Ja, einfach Game abgebrochen und die sind live auf einem Event, darf man nicht vergessen. Die sitzen in ihrer Box und spielen.
Guck mal, der ist mega-pissed, der ist mega-pissed, guck mal, der ist mega-pissed.
Ich kann es aber auch verstehen, ich meine, du spielst das gleiche Game schon zum zweiten Mal und du bist ja auch voll dabei.
Du spielst das ja auf der Bühne nicht auf halber Arschbacke, also du bist wirklich da engaged, du bist da richtig voll dabei und dann so eine Kacke, Alter.
Fucking Singleplayer.
Da muss ich ihm tatsächlich nur zum Teil zustimmen, ein verspätetes Spiel muss nicht unbedingt gut sein.
Das heißt im Prinzip, ein verspätetes Spiel ist letztendlich gut, aber ein zu früh oder gehetzt erstelltes Game ist für immer schlecht.
Ja, stimmt, aber es kann am Ende gut sein.
Nein, Eventually heißt nicht vielleicht, Eventually heißt sowas wie letztendlich, das ist eines der häufigsten Englisch-Gebates, die es gibt, Eventually heißt nicht vielleicht.
Man denkt das, weil man eventuell in Deutsch kommt, aber es heißt letztendlich, das ist ein Englisch-Gebate auf den ich, genau, schließlich letztendlich endlich heißt das.
Das ist ein Englisch-Gebate, auf den ich selbst oft reingefallen habe, viele Aussagen nicht verstanden, bis ich mir irgendwann mal gemerkt habe, okay, das ist eines der häufigsten Gebates, die man im Kopf hat,
dass es nicht vielleicht eventuell heißt, sondern tatsächlich endlich, ah, okay, irgendwann, alles klar, es gibt auch wohl die Variante, das als irgendwann zu verwenden.
Okay, irgendwann trifft es, wenn er sagt, ein verspieltes Game ist irgendwann mal gut und ein vereiltes Spiel ergibt Sinn, aber es heißt auf jeden Fall nicht vielleicht.
Da habe ich mich auch schon oft gebeten lassen, sowas nennt man false friend, echt, da gibt es ein Wort für, das wusste ich gar nicht, dass es dafür ein Wort gibt, false friend.
Became gleich bekommen, nee, ja, genau, sowas in der Richtung, Became heißt sowas wie wurde oder so, ne, warte mal, Became, ja, wurden, werden, nee, nein, Became, das ist schon was, was vorbei ist.
Became ist, es ist schon rum, genau, Became ist Englisch, Deutsch, wurden, genau, bin ich da über Englisch pro, aber manche Sachen kriege ich dann doch hin.
Ja, ja.
Ja, Bungie, Bungie kriegt glaube ich langsam, aber sichert die Kurve wieder seit sie weg sind von EA.
Richtig, das ist das Problem.
Äh, von Activation, nicht von EA, von Activation, ja, was, den ganzen Scheiß kann sich doch keiner merken.
Ihr habt Recht.
Spann die nicht Destiny 2 doch.
Ihr müsst euch mal, wenn ihr wirklich den riesen Unterschied sehen wollt, quasi Entwickler, die hinter ihren Spielen stehen und die Spiele quasi entwickeln quasi auch ein bisschen für sich selbst, wie es ihnen Spaß macht, ihr müsst euch mal alte BlizzCon Auftritte angucken.
Es gibt einen Auftritt, da ist Jeff Kaplan, der Overwatch Mensch jetzt, der war ja früher World of Warcraft Content Designer, der stellt sich auf die Bühne und sagt, ich glaube das Beispiel habe ich schon einmal erzählt, der stellt sich auf die Bühne und sagt, man soll schlechte Spieler aus der Party kicken.
Sinngemäß, ja, also er verpackt das ein bisschen lustiger, da sagt der, der erzählt darauf, der erzählt sowas in der Richtung wie, ja und ihr habt immer einen in der Gruppe, zum Beispiel irgendwie, ihr habt immer einen Heiler in der Gruppe, der nicht heilt und einen Tank in der Gruppe, der nicht tankt und da sagt er immer, und ihr kennt das alle, ihr wollt ihn kicken, so.
Das sind so Sachen, die würden sich heute im Leben nicht trauen, da wird sich sofort jemand offendet fühlen.
Wenn heute sich mal Blizard einer auf die Bühne stellt und sagt, Leute, wenn ihr einen habt mit zwei linken Händen in der Gruppe, der den, der als Heiler nicht halten, als Tank nicht tankt, kickt ihn raus, da würde sich so zuerst, zuerst der, keine Ahnung, der Sprecher des Zentralrats der äh äh was weiß ich,
Menschen mit zwei linken händen behinderten menschen melden und sagen ja aber blizzard wir sind offended
Wie kannst du es wagen jemand aus der gruppe zu kicken weil er schlecht ist vielleicht hat er körperliche
Beeinträchtigungen und kann deswegen nicht richtig spielen ihr seid ganz ganz böse blizzard
Danach kommt der
was weiß ich
der zentralrat der oder was gibt es auch irgendwie der f der verein der
der
Berufsmelder der
Handwerker und sagt dann ja das geht aber nicht weil der typ hat vielleicht den ganzen tag hart
gearbeitet und möchte dann am ende nur in ruhe ein bisschen entspannt spielen und er kann seine hand nicht mehr richtig benutzen weil er ist ja
Schreiner hat sich heute vielleicht mit dem hammer auf die hand gehauen und deswegen das könnt ihr nicht machen blizzard ihr
Diskriminiert ganz viele leute da werden alle wieder mega empört
Ja, und es wird sich jeder der sich empören kann empören wenn er das wenn das heute blizzard auf der bühne machen würde es gibt
Zwei möglichkeiten damit irgendwie umzugehen denke ich
Entweder man macht das so wie es die meisten firmen machen
Nämlich nach möglichkeit soweit es möglich ist das zu umschiffen und sobald irgendwas ist
Quasi sachen zu löschen man darf nicht vergessen in call of duty in modern warfare ist jetzt das ok
symbol mit der hand entfernt worden weil
sich leute beschwert haben das wäre ja angeblich ein white white power white
supremacy
patriarchat gedöns symbol
Und das wurde jetzt entfernt kann ich aus bösen es sich nachvollziehen die wollen
jeglichem
möglichen
shitstorm im ansatz
sich entziehen die zweite variante was man machen könnte ist und ich finde das müssten mehr leute machen
Einfach mal sagen wie es ist dass alle leute sich mal einkriegen sollen
Es heißt nicht dass man wichtige themen ignorieren soll ganz das gegenteil man sollte wichtige themen nicht
von haus aus unterbinden überall sondern einfach mal drüber reden und bei manchen sachen auch mal wirklich so
so viel so viel
Wie sagt man eier in der hose haben zu sagen ok dafür passen wir unser spiel nicht an
Also stellt euch mal nicht so an
Weil eine sache wozu das führt ist meiner ansicht nach geht alles hier immer nur meine meinung umso mehr man
den extremen entgegen kommt
umso
abgedrehter werden die forderungen
also sprich
wenn ich heute
eine geste aus dem spiel entfernen weil es
Eventuell und wir reden hier nicht von einem harten kreuz oder sowas ja da wird keiner diskutieren dass so was
Das ist klar wie wir reden hier von von irgendwelchen gesten wo sich um einen ford chant roll handelt
Oder andere sachen wenn man heute damit anfängt solche sachen ohne jegliche diskussion oder ohne irgendwas um quasi
sich voraus eilend zu entfernen dann ist das nicht dann werden die forderungen und und der outrage den
Stahl gibt die werden immer extremer
Es ist nicht so dass es weniger wird es wird immer extremer als nächstes kommt dann ok
Es dürfen keine figuren mehr finger haben weil weil wenn du finger hast dann können die figuren in den games ja
Zeichen machen die rassistisch diskriminieren was auch immer sind also keine figuren mehr finger dann wird das gemacht als nächstes kommt dann
Ja, aber da sind weiße texturen drin und wir wissen dass alles weiße schlecht ist ok weiße texturen rausgemacht und am ende kannst du ja nur noch
ein spiel machen was aus
Keine ahnung
einem transparenten fenster besteht ohne mit wiese dass ich keiner mehr aus aufregen kann
also
Man muss man darf nicht so extrem
Alles blind immer machen weil es wird es wird umso mehr den extremen forderung entgegenkommst
um so um so abgedrehter wird
Um so abgedrehter werden die forderung immer
Deswegen bin ich ja auch in fern von dass man einfach über sachen mal diskutiert anstatt sie anstatt sie zu verbieten zu verbieten oder tot zu schweigen
Und ich finde ich persönlich finde es komplett komplett bescheuert dass man solche gesten rausnimmt ja
Es gibt gesten die sind ganz klar irgendwie
Beleidigend gemeint ja also angenommen es gibt einen mittelfinger emote ok
Das ist kommt jetzt auch ein bisschen drauf an in welchem kulturkreis man sich bewegt es mag bestimmt die ein oder anderen
Kulturen
Weltanschauung geben wo der mittelfinger was gut ist nicht schlecht ist was weiß ich
Aber gehen wir mal von uns aus wenn man jetzt sagen wird ok es gibt einen emote wo wo man irgendwie dem gegner den man gerade
Gekillt hat dass man den auch mal so richtig so so
Disrespekten kann tbacken kann noch mittelfinger wenn man sagt ok das emote nimmt man raus könnte ich noch irgendwo nachvollziehen aber auch da würde ich sagen
warum
also wenn man wenn man so
Extrem leicht beseitigt ist dass man es in einem multiplayer pvp spiel nicht ertragen kann
wenn wenn man quasi mal in einem pvp game
mit mittelfinger gezeigt kriegt ja gut
Dann ist man vielleicht im falschen game aber das könnte ich noch verstehen aber wenn man dann anfängt immer immer
unsinnigere dinger durchzusetzen um nach möglichkeit jedem jedem auch nur
Theoretisch möglichen shitstorm zu entgehen dann wird man darauf rauslaufen dass man unterm strich nichts mehr machen kann und nichts mehr sagen kann
Womit letztendlich auch keinem geholfen ist
Was kommt da raus da kommt dann nur noch
absolut langweiliger einheitsprei raus der sich mehr mühe gibt bei keinem anzuecken als das wirklich
Da ein gutes game bei rauskommt
Das da kann auch keiner was von haben
Könnt ihr euch noch an die an diese cs-go map erinnern die in der türkei gespielt hat
Es gab mal in es gab mal in cs-go in den map pack da gab es eine map
Die hatten der türkei gespielt und dort gab es graffiti an der wand wo sie den den staatsgründer der türkei
irgendwie als kamelreiter oder oder
Eselreiter oder irgendwie sowas also irgendwie in der türkische beleidigung an die wand geschmiert haben auf also auf türkisch ja
und
Nene nicht verwehler wir reden hier von cs es gab eine cs map die an der türkei gespielt eine ziemlich unbekannte map
die hat damals so für ein bisschen wind gesorgt als sie rausgekommen ist so und
Da war der aufschrei extrem groß wie ist das denn
Vergessen wie die heißt war das mal kurz kurz
Vergessen wie die heißt war doch mal das mal kurz gucken
Wie heißt die map
Atlanta die integratinger verschiedenen various
Gag tiedig
Wie klar die map mein ich so und da haben sich alle extrem drüber darüber aufgeregt
Sexy Kebab, wo ich sagen kann, ja okay, wenn es einen persönlich betrifft, ist es sicherlich ärgerlich.
Ob man jetzt auf Grundlage dessen,
okay, auf Grundlage dessen kann man fordern, ja, das soll aus dem Game raus.
Aber ich bin immer, ich habe damals glaube ich sogar ein Video zu gemacht, wo ich sage, okay, ich kann verstehen, wenn man da persönlich von betroffen ist und
dass den Typ halt gut findet und er wird beleidigt, dass man das nicht schön findet, dass man das, dass man da ein bisschen
angefressen ist, kann ich verstehen.
Aber ich meine, es ist schon ein ganz schön ausgeholt von einer CSGO Map zu die
die Ehre wird beleidigt, ja, oder sowas.
Also, ich weiß ja nicht, was mit den Leuten los ist, die meisten Leute können Ehre noch nicht mal definieren, wenn du sie fragst, was bedeutet Ehre.
Und ob man da jetzt drauf einlenken muss als Spielehersteller, ist fraglich.
Weil letztendlich, egal was du machst, es gibt immer einen, den es stört und wenn du bei jedem Furz
dein Produkt anpasst, oder bei jedem Furz auf irgendwas eingehst, du machst ja den ganzen Tag nichts anderes mehr.
Du kommst auf eher, weil das auf der Newsseite gerade stand.
Weil das gerade auf der Newsseite gestanden hat.
Und das ist dann schon ein ziemlich, ziemlich, ziemlich weit
gestretched von einer CSGO Map zu
die Ehre des türkischen Folges wird beleidigt, ja.
Ich finde Sachen auch nicht toll, ich finde auch nicht alle Sachen toll, ja.
Keine Ahnung, wenn man mal vorausgeht, ihr wisst, ich bin absolut ungläubig, was das angeht, also
ich hab's weder mit christlichen Sachen, noch mit islamischen Sachen, noch mit hinduistischen Sachen.
Mir geht jegliche Gottesgeschichten sonst wo vorbei.
Aber mal angenommen, ich wäre jetzt voll gläubisch christlich, natürlich wird's mich abfacken.
Wenn irgendwie einer anfangen würde, sich darüber lustig zu machen, ja, aber ich glaube nicht, dass ich fordern würde, dass der
quasi seine Werke jetzt löschen soll.
Es gab ja letztens auch
die Harry Potter Autorin, ne wir sind noch nicht ganz durch, ich bin wieder am Schwätzen gerade.
Die Harry Potter Autorin hat sich letztens an irgendeinem
Brief zur Meinungsfreiheit
beteiligt, also an einem offenen Brief zur Meinungsfreiheit beteiligt, den hat die unterschrieben.
Die hat auch in letzter Zeit ein paar komische Dinge auf Twitter wieder von sich gegeben
und die hat auch öfter Stress auf Twitter mit transsexuellen Leuten, also die Harry Potter Autorin,
also die ist da nicht ganz unumstritten.
Zumindest hat die sich auch dran beteiligt an einem Brief, an einem offenen Brief, wo es um Meinungsfreiheit ging
und da haben wirklich ernsthaft Leute drauf geantwortet. Man darf nicht vergessen, die Leute
mögen die Bücher, es ist auch erstmal scheißegal, was die Autorin sagt, also wenn denen die Bücher gefallen, wenn die mit den Büchern aufgewachsen sind,
wenn die quasi Harry Potter-Fan sind,
diese, krass, wie lange diese Serie gelaufen ist, zehn Jahre mit den Filmen, also diese schöne Erfahrung und Zeit
wird jetzt ja nicht dadurch vernichtet, dass die Autorin was sagt, was ihnen vielleicht nicht gut ist,
wird jetzt ja nicht dadurch vernichtet irgendwie, dass die Autorin was sagt, was ihnen vielleicht nicht gefällt
und die haben ernsthaft gesagt, sie werden jetzt alle, könnt ihr nachgucken auf Twitter, auf die Antwort da drauf,
die werden jetzt alle ihre Harry Potter Bücher zusammensuchen und sie öffentlich verbrennen.
Wo ich mir gedacht hab, alter Leute, seid ihr noch, seid ihr noch alle ganz dicht, ja, ihr fangt jetzt wieder an Bücher zu verbrennen oder was,
weil einer was gesagt hat, was uns nicht gefällt.
Also, es sind, es nimmt mittlerweile Ausmaße an, mit empört sein, das ist nicht mehr normal, es ist echt nicht mehr normal.
Jeder ist über jeden Scheiß, an jeder Stelle empört und regt sich auf und erwartet, dass die gesamte Welt mitmacht, total wir.
Also ich verstehe die Welt heute an vielen Stellen gar nicht mehr.
So, wir sind eigentlich zu gut wie durch mit dem Video.
Das Ubisoft Event ist heute Abend 21 Uhr. Ich muss gleich mal gucken, ob wirklich 21 Uhr ist.
Ja, so viel.
Far Cry 6 gibt es wohl eher und keine Ahnung.
Und die meisten Videos haben kommentiere nicht. Und wenn du in die Erinnerung gehst, dass Blizzard gesagt hat, dass sie auf Overwatch 2 etwas schief gehen wollen,
kumple das mit dem Diablo 4 Reveal und es sieht einfach so aus, als wäre es ein zartes Versuch, die Spieler zu konzentrieren,
von welchem Scheiß-Head-Kompanie sie gewesen sind, zu, wow, schau dir diese neuen Titel an! Aber das ist nur meine Theorie.
Blizzard hat wieder und wieder gezeigt, wo ihre Morale liegen. Und das ist nicht mehr mit den Konsumenten.
Das hier? Warum ist der eine Trailer 137 unter anderem 5 Tage?
Also ich fand Shadow Warrior 1 und 2 ziemlich gut, die Remakes.
Wo ist Weng? Ich brauche Weng!
Ist das Weng? Sah Weng nicht irgendwie anders aus in Teil 2?
Vor allem der hat die Maske von dem Typ aus Teil 1 auf.
Doch vom Sprecher her ist das Weng.
Okay, viel hat man jetzt nicht gesehen.
Also auf jeden Fall der gleiche Sprecher.
Dennis, ich kann jetzt nicht so genau das herstellen von dem, was du in deinem Comment schreibst,
zu dem, was ich da die letzten zwei Stunden an manchen Stellen verteilt gesagt habe.
Komme ich jetzt nicht ganz mit. Jeder darf sich, wenn es nach mir geht, für alles aussprechen, was er will.
Habe ich überhaupt keine Probleme mit. Vollkommen okay.
Ich habe auch gar keine Probleme mit, wenn sich Leute über irgendwas empören. Sollen sie das doch machen.
Darf jeder sagen, was er will. In gewissen Grenzen.
Aber die Grenzen sind teilweise, finde ich heute, ein bisschen zu eng.
Es gibt noch einen Gameplay Trailer. Der da wahrscheinlich.
Ah. Irgendwie sieht Weng anders aus als in Teil 2. Oder briege ich es jetzt durcheinander.
Doch, ich fand Shadow Warrior richtig nice. Kann ich übrigens jedem nur empfehlen, auch den zweiten Teil zu spielen.
Was ich mich frage ist. Schreckt.
Ich frage mich, ob die wieder so Loot-Mechaniken drin haben, wie im zweiten Teil oder nicht.
Im ersten Teil gab es ja, weiß gar nicht, ob es da überhaupt Loot im klassischen Sinn gegeben hat.
Ich glaube nicht. Zweiter Teil war ja halbes Borderlands, was Loot angeht.
Fast schon ein bisschen viel fand ich.
Wobei die Nahkampf-Mechanik war cool.
Sieht so aus, wie ein Doom, nur Asiatischer ist es ja im Endeffekt auch.
Das ist das Shadow Warrior 3 Trailer gewesen.
Ich hatte sogar mal ein Video mit Shadow Warrior 2 drin.
Ich glaube, das war das Video, was ich zur GTX 1080 Ti gemacht habe.
Da ist ein bisschen Shadow Warrior 2 Gameplay drin gewesen hier.
Das Nahkampfsystem von Shadow Warrior 2 fand ich echt nice.
Du hattest ziemlich verschiedene Waffen.
Dual-Wheel-Waffen, Singlehand-Waffen, Waffen, die irgendwie über Range.
Und du hattest dann irgendwelche Power-Ups noch. Du konntest verschiedene Fähigkeiten machen.
Und du konntest auch verschiedene Nahkampf-Moves machen.
Ich fand es echt genau. Du konntest nach links drücken, da hast du links geschlagen, rechts geschlagen, nach vorne, nach hinten.
Das war echt cool.
Erst mal vor einer Runde oftmals erst, ob das jetzt...
Ja, bla, bla, bla, Max.
Gibt so ein bisschen Action.
Was sieht?
Aber...
Es waren allesamt echt coole Games.
Nur die, da sich ein bisschen viel Gelute gab es im zweiten Teil, fand ich.
Alter, drei Stunden habe ich mich jetzt wirklich über ein 37-Minuten-Video, keine Ahnung, zwei Stunden ausgelassen, kann das sein?
Wie lang habe ich mich über das Video ausgelassen jetzt? Mit 50.000 Side-Tracks?
Gut, ich habe mich aber auch wieder über Gott und die Welt ausgelassen, ne?
Jetzt macht das täglich 50.000 Subscriber-Ink.
Ich glaube, ich kann mich nicht täglich zu dem ganzen Zeug auslassen.
Ich kann noch was trinken, ja.
Biggest Digges.
Wie hatten sie das nochmal auf Deutsch übersetzt?
Was? Ich glaube, Longus Schwanzus oder so hatten sie das, glaube ich, in Deutsch.
Oder nicht Schwanzus, Longus, genau.
Nicht Longus, Schwanzus.
Auch so ein Ding, ganz ehrlich, ich kann den riesen Hype um die Monty-Python-Filme nicht so wirklich verstehen.
Die sind teilweise ganz witzig, aber jetzt so, die absolut Ultra-Meister-Werke wieder angedichtet wird, sehe ich jetzt für mich nicht so.
Wo wir wieder beim Thema sind, jeder was ihm gefällt, ja.
Ok, Leute, ich hab Hunger, ich hab übelst Kohldampf.
Ranking all my smart home products and projects, smart home tour.
Das ist so was, was der Chat schon die ganze Zeit von mir will, dass ich mal eine Home-Tour mache, aber ich mache immer keine Home-Tour.
Weil ich dazu viel leake, wenn ich eine Home-Tour mache.
Leaked überall.
Das ist aber ein Video, was mich persönlich echt interessiert, weil ich gucke den Channel gerne.
Da nimm mal ganz gute Themen.
Der hat ein Haus, also der Typ hat es echt übertrieben.
Der hat ein Haus mit RGB-Beleuchtung.
Der hat sein komplettes Haus RGB beleuchtet von außen.
Der ist wirklich nicht mehr normal.
Warte mal, das Video interessiert mich persönlich, das gucken wir jetzt noch.
Und ich esse nebenbei ein paar Nudeln.
Today on the hookup, I'm gonna take you on a tour of my extensive smart home setup and rank each of my improvements on a tier list to help you spend your money wisely when it comes to smart home projects.
RGB, ja, was meinst du, was der für Frames in Games hat mit dem RGB-Haus?
Having a YouTube channel devoted to smart home tech pretty much gives me a free pass to test out any new smart home product as it comes available.
Sometimes the results are revolutionary.
But occasionally they turn out to be a massive waste of time, money, and energy.
As I give you the grand tour...
Okay, broken.
War das nicht deine Musik von der Battlefield 5 später?
Doch.
So, ich hab jetzt keine Serviette geholt, ich hab mir ein Handtuch geholt.
Das reicht jetzt zum Abfuss, Alter.
Ich hab voll rumgesaut mit den Nudeln.
Nudeln mit Tomatensauce, das heißt, wenn die sauen, dann sauen die richtig, ja.
So, Video.
Sachen ranken ist voll angesagt zurzeit.
Wer kocht für dich, das ist übrig vom Lieferstellz.
What?
Moment, jetzt sind Home-Automatisierungsvideos schon gesponsert?
Okay.
Okay, Werbung.
Okay, sind wir noch nicht fertig?
Ah, jetzt gleich fertig.
Okay, 100.000 Abonnenten, das ist ziemlich verrückt.
Lass uns mein Haus sehen.
Das ist so krass, der hat mal ein Video drüber gezeigt.
Ich will nicht wissen, wie viel FPS der in Spielen hat.
Ohne Handtuch lippt man gefährlich, ja.
Ja, das braucht keiner.
Lohnen tut sich nicht, aber es ist ein geiles Projekt.
Ich habe nicht so viele, man sieht hier gerade die Übersicht von ihm.
Mittlerweile habe ich Kameras.
Hoftor.
Hof.
Flur.
Keller.
Keller für die Heizung.
Eine habe ich noch vergessen.
Achso, nee.
Achso, und eine, wo ich die Katze beobachten kann immer.
Lieblingsliegeplatz, da habe ich noch eine Kamera hingemacht.
Der hat ein bisschen mehr aufgerüstet als bei mir.
Aber Kameras ist wirklich eines der ersten Sachen, die sich lohnt,
selbst wenn man nicht mit Smart Home anfängt, weil man einfach
ein bisschen Übersicht haben will, was passiert im Zweifelsfall,
auch mitbekommen möchte, wenn irgendein Amazon Typ das Paket
immer einfach über das Tor pfeffert.
Ich nehme übrigens nichts stahlermäßig auf.
Kannst du da was empfehlen oder alles selbst erstellt?
Ja, also nee, ich habe nicht alles selbst erstellt.
Das Einzige, was ich selbst erstellt habe, ist eine Raspberry Pi Cam
für das Hoftor.
Der Rest sind fertig gekaufte Kameras, aber ich habe noch keine
so wirklich gute gefunden, die preisleistungsmäßig gut ist
und alles kann, was ich will.
Ich habe jetzt so ein Sammelsurium aus ein paar Kameras.
Das Video und Trigger Full Resolution Recording.
Nicht nur geben mir diese Kameras mir Peace of Mind,
weil ich weiß, dass mein Zuhause immer unter Verwaltung ist,
aber sie sind extrem nötig, um Kinder zu halten,
während sie draußen spielen.
Ich muss gerade mal gucken, ob ich euch die Kamera über sich zeigen kann
oder ob ich wieder irgendwas leake.
Nee, ich leake, ich leake was, ich kann euch nichts zeigen.
Ich leake.
Haha.
Das ist eine Klimaanlage?
Oder was hat der da?
Das ist ja eine riesen Klimaanlage.
Is das alles eine Klimaanlage?
What the fuck?
Ist das die Kokona Style?
Ich meine, ich habe schon eine ziemlich große,
gute Klimaanlage hier, aber bei mir ist das
so ein Ding an der Wand.
Drei Stück? Okay, das sind die Amis, da weiß man nicht genau was da ist. Der muss bestimmt auch, der muss bestimmt auch, keine Ahnung, das Dachgeschoss, die Klimaanlage machen.
Lager, Lagerraum in der Garage braucht eine Klimaanlage wahrscheinlich bei denen.
Was hältst du von Nubiquity Camps? Ziemlich gut, aber eigentlich zu teuer.
Ja, ja, würde ich auch so sagen. Ja, hat er recht.
Wow. Und dann Fußbodenheizung im Bad, ja. Was? Moment. Was ist das? Nein. Nein. Nein. Einfach nur nein.
Nein. Es gibt ein paar Sachen und ihr wisst, ich bin sehr technikaffin was Smart Home angeht. Es gibt aber eine Sache, die kommt mir auch die nächsten Jahre nicht in die Tüte und das ist ein Smart Lock an der Haustür.
Im Leben nicht. Die ganzen Konstruktionen, die sich, wenn man sich, wenn man sich anschaut was da in den vergangenen Jahren passiert ist, sind so hochgradig unsicher und so kaputt. Im Leben nicht. Im Leben nicht.
Gut, ich meine das ist ein Ami Haus. Die haben im Prinzip eh nur Holzwände. Da kommst du quasi in jeder anderen Stelle genauso gut rein als durch die Fronttür. Wahrscheinlich ist es einfacher durch die Wand zu gehen als statt durch die Fronttür zu gehen. Aber im Leben nicht. Nein.
Smart Locks kommen bei mir nicht ins Haus. Nirgendwo hin. Im Haus vielleicht. Also sprich, wenn man jetzt sagt, ok, ich hab ne, ich will die Tür zum Bad abschließen. Keine Ahnung, dass ich abschließen kann, wenn ich mal kacken muss. Meinetwegen könnte man das mit dem Smart Lock machen, warum auch immer man das machen sollte. Aber nicht die Haustür. Nicht die Haustür. Fürs Büro vielleicht, ja. Aber nicht für die Haustür, auf gar keinen Fall.
Für den Serverraum. Nee, aber im Serverraum muss ich keinen Smart Lock machen. Also bei meinem Serverraum ist es einfacher durch die Wand zu gehen als durch die Tür, wenn du wirklich rein willst. Das sind einfach nur Gipswände, die, keine Ahnung, 2 cm Gipswände oder so.
Also wenn du mal richtig fest gegen die Wand trittst zu meinem Serverraum, ist ein Loch drin.
Die habe ich auch.
Die habe ich auch. Nee, das sind Shelly 2.5, die habe ich nicht. Ich habe ein paar Shelly Wands. Das sind die für mehrere Switche in einem.
Beste Leute, beste was es gibt. Komplett offline. Also die Dinger haben zwar die Webseite Shelly.cloud, aber das Verkaufargument ist, dass man die Dinger offline verwenden kann. Warum auch immer die dann ein.cloud Domain haben.
Mustafa sagt, ich weiß nicht, wieso man so viel Smart Home überhaupt haben sollte. Wirkt richtig unsicher. Ja, du hast vollkommen recht. Deswegen würde ich auch empfehlen, wenn man sich dafür interessiert, die sicheren Sachen zu machen.
Weil, was braucht man in Smart Lock? Komplett unsicher. Aber zum Beispiel Rollladen, dass man Rollladen automatisch machen kann. Das ist was, das macht das Ganze weder sicherer noch unsicherer.
Security Kameras machen das Ganze weder sicherer noch unsicherer. Dass du beispielsweise eine Steuerung hast für deine Heizung macht das Ganze weder sicherer noch unsicherer.
Es macht es nur angenehmer, dass du vielleicht den ein oder anderen Lichtschalter automatisiert oder übers Tablet ein- und ausschalten kannst. Macht die Sache auch nicht unsicherer, aber viel angenehmer.
Ein bisschen Beleuchtung. Ich habe beispielsweise hier so eine RGB Lampe, die eingestellt wird je nachdem wie viel Verspätung mein Zug morgens hat. Macht die Sache auch nicht unsicherer, aber angenehmer.
Deswegen würde ich immer sagen, man sollte beim Smart Home mit den Sachen anfangen, die das Leben für einen angenehmer machen. Also die Sachen, die es am angenehmsten machen zuerst.
Und dann halt auch die Dinge, die es nicht unsicher machen. Normale Schlüssel knackst du genauso schnell mit einem Tietrich. Da bin ich mir je nach Schloss und Tür gar nicht mal so sicher.
Außerdem musst du da physikalisch ran und was können. Je nach App reicht teilweise schon der falsche Link, dass die Dinge aufgegangen sind.
Aber die Shelley-Teile sind wirklich gut. Es gibt viele Lampen. Da steht dran, jedes nochmal weitere IoT im Haushalt macht das private Netzwerk unsicherer.
Deswegen hängt man die ja auch nicht bei sich privat ins Netz rein. Wenn man das richtig macht oder wenn man das ein bisschen advanceder macht, richtig ist eh richtig und falsch gibt es ja in der Form bei sowas nicht.
Da macht man das ja auch anders. Da hat man ein privates internes Netz. Da kommen nur Sachen rein, die wirklich sicher sind. Ein paar Kabel.
Dann hast du vielleicht noch einen WLAN für deine Tablets. Du hast vielleicht noch einen Gäste-WLAN. Und dann hast du für so Sachen wie China-Kamera und IoT hast du entweder eins oder zwei extra WLANs.
Auch mit Client-Isolation, dass die sich nicht untereinander erreichen können. Und ja, dann hast du theoretisch immer noch den Fall, jedes Gerät, also die reinen Leere ist das ja so.
Jedes Gerät, jedes Software, die man zusätzlich zum Default installiert, birgt Angriffsrisiko. Aber ich schätze das als recht gering ein, wenn du beispielsweise WLAN-Steckdosen hast.
Und die hast du in einem eigenen IoT-Netzwerk, wo sich Geräte untereinander nicht erreichen dürfen und man auch nur in das Netzwerk rein darf und von diesem Netzwerk nicht raus.
Kein Internetzugang. Das ist ja eh das erste, was bei mir geblockt ist. Also sprich, keiner der China-Geräte hat noch oder die meisten haben keine originale Firmware mehr.
Und die, die noch normale Firmware haben, kommen dann auch nicht ins Internet.
Also richtig gemacht, würde ich sagen, überwiegt der Vorteil von IoT und Smart Home gegenüber den Nachteilen.
Natürlich nur, wenn man das richtig ordentlich macht und zum größten Teil selbst macht, mit fertigen Lösungen wäre ich da auch vorsichtig.
Der normale User, der sollte es vielleicht auch bleiben lassen dann, wenn der sich einfach nur was hinstellt und Passwort 123456 vergibt, ja.
Das sehe ich auch so. Das ist problematisch. Vor allem, nachdem diese Systeme dann oftmals halt eben auch als sicher angepriesen werden, was sie nicht sind.
Übrigens, eine der praktischsten Sachen ever ist der Staubsäuber-Roboter mit Custom-Firmware. Der hier.
Das ist so ein praktisches Teil.
Der hat sich neu gestartet.
Der hat sich neu gestartet. Letztens sehe ich hier gerade.
Wie dem auch sei, der Staubsäuber-Roboter mit Custom-Firmware.
Die Custom-Firmware sorgt dafür, der Staubsäuber-Roboter hat einen Web-Interface, was er standardmäßig nicht hat.
Also sprich, man kann sich die Karte vom Wohnzimmer angucken zum Beispiel.
Und auch hier manuell steuern drüber. Also viel mehr als mit der App.
Und das Schöne ist, durch die Custom-Firmware kann man den auch steuern.
Desmond, ja ich hatte auch einmal den Reset-Bug, seitdem ich jetzt letztens wieder geflasht habe, nicht mehr.
Grundflasche League. Ja vom Wohnzimmer. MonkaS.
Es gibt bestimmt ganz wenige Häuser, die ein Wohnzimmer in dieser ungefähren Größe haben.
Ist der Bug eigentlich gefixt? Ich weiß es nicht.
Ich weiß es nicht. Müssen wir mal gucken. Schreib ich mal auf. Du wolltest mal nachher nachgucken.
Na gut. Zumindest die Staubsäuber-Roboter kann ich definitiv empfehlen.
Guck mal weiter. Und wer sich überlegt, Lichter in sein Smart-Home einzubauen,
beziehungsweise Lichter automatisch an und aus machen zu können und sowas,
ich würde dringend, wirklich ganz eindringlich euch empfehlen, es so zu machen, wie er im Video hier,
nämlich mit Shelly-Relay-Switches oder mit Sonoff-Relay-Switches, was auch immer.
Weil, wenn man anfängt mit Smart-Light-Bulbs oder mit Smart-Beleuchtung,
die einen WLAN-Chip drin haben, über die man sie ein- und ausschalten kann, hat man ein Problem.
Sobald die Stromzufuhr zur Lampe ausgeschaltet wird, geht das WLAN auch nicht mehr in der Lampe.
Das heißt, es ist viel besser, wenn man eine Beleuchtung hat.
Man macht eine stinknormale, klassische Beleuchtung mit normaler Lampe drin, macht allerdings den Schalter smart.
Und das kann man mit so einem Unterputz-Relay machen. Davon habe ich auch ein paar von den Shelly-Geräten.
Da schließt man die Lampe an, man schließt den Schalter an und man kann dann über das WLAN das Relay ein- und ausschalten
und über den Schalter das Relay ein- und ausschalten, was dann wiederum die Lampe schaltet.
Also sprich, man kann nach wie vor den Schalter verwenden und man kann es über die Heimautomatisierung machen.
Was viel besser ist, als einfach so eine WLAN-Lampe zu haben, wo man dann auf einmal seinen Lichtschalter nicht mehr verwenden darf,
weil sie sonst zufällig ausgeht und gar nicht mehr funktioniert.
Also, das ist die bessere Variante.
Wir haben Yeelight mit MQTT-Schalter in der Wand.
Okay, wenn man sowas advancedes hat, wenn man quasi schon keine normalen Lichtschalter mehr hat, sondern quasi IoT-fähige Schalter,
dann sieht die Sache wieder anders aus.
Aber die meisten Häuser, die haben halt noch so klassische, äh, ja, so, nip-snap, so dick normale Schalter drinne.
Und, ähm, die habe ich bei uns auch mit dem Shelly 1 abgecrate.
Die kann ich jetzt übers Tablet ein- und ausschalten und über den Schalter ein- und ausschalten.
Welcher Staubsauger ist das? Ähm, das ist ein Roborock S50.
Show me! Xi-Xiaomi! Roborock S50 mit Kassenfirma.
Ähm, sind das Touch-Schalter?
Finko, sind das Touch-Schalter oder haben die richtige Knöpfe?
Weil ich mag keine Touch-Schalter.
So sehr ich Touch-Screens mag, aber Schalt-Nee mag ich nicht.
Ich, ich, ich mag keine Touch-Schalter.
Ich mag keine Touch-Schalter.
So sehr ich Touch-Screens mag, aber Schalt-Nee mag ich nicht.
Ich, ich, ich mag Knöpfe.
Knöpfe, so richtige Knöpfe.
Ich drück gerne auf Knöpfe drauf und merke, wenn der Knopf gedrückt ist.
Ich mag keine Touch-Bedienung.
Also Touch für Schalter mag ich nicht.
Buttons und Schalter, beste.
Ähm, die, ich hab ja so zwei Control-Panels.
Also sprich, ich hab ein Fire-TV-Tablet oben hängen im Flur und ein Fire,
nicht ein Fire-TV, ein Fire-Tablet, ein Fire-HD-Tablet unten im Flur und eins oben im Flur
für so ein bisschen Dashboard an der Wand.
Das ist auch Touch.
Aber so richtig Schalter drücken, das ist besseres Feedback für ein und aus, finde ich.
Ja.
Mittlerweile, mittlerweile guckt meine Katze sogar zu, wenn der rumfährt.
Die legt sich dann auf Sofa und guckt von oben runter, wenn der im Wohnzimmer rumfährt.
Und manchmal versucht sie auch drauf zu hauen.
Okay, ich hab keine Fische.
Das kommt mir nicht ins Haus.
Keine.
Ich stell mir kein Amazon Echo hin.
Es sei denn, es sei denn, da hab ich mich in letzter Zeit nicht wirklich viel mit beschäftigt,
es sei denn, es gibt entweder eine Custom-Firma dafür oder eine verlässliche Möglichkeit,
den Kram zu blocken zu Amazon und dass sie weiter funktionieren.
Die Speaker sehen aber auch aus wie 20 Jahre alt.
Kennst du das Roomba-Video? Du meinst das Video, wo er gegen die Wand fährt und schreit? Ja, das kenn ich.
Weiß ich, mir war's grad so.
Das Motor auf den Amazon raus. Wenn's das gäbe, ich wär der Erste, der am Weihnachts-Sale einen 10er-Pack
Amazon-Geräte kaufen und erst mal flasht.
Ich würde nachts um 1, um 0 Uhr und 1 Sekunde, sobald es losgeht der Weihnachts-Sale,
dann würde ich bestellen, am besten automatisch über irgendeinen Skript nachts bestellen und direkt flashen.
Sobald's das gibt. Aber leider geht das bei Amazon-Dingern noch nicht.
Da warte ich drauf. Da warte ich echt drauf. Das wär huge.
Der Knopf sieht ganz schön wackelig aus.
Also, ich hab keinen Dimmer. Die einzige Sache, die ich dimmen konnte, war mal mein selbst gebaute Weihnachtsbaum-Beleuchtung.
Kennt ihr die noch? Hab ich euch mal gezeigt? Weihnachtsbaum.
Moment, wo ist mein Weihnachtsbaum?
Baum. Moment. Beleuchtung.
Baum.
Oh, ist meine Weihnachtsbaum. Ich will euch noch mal meine Weihnachtsbaum-Beleuchtung zeigen.
Was ist mit ESP32 vielleicht?
Muss irgendwann an Weihnachten sein.
RGB.
Baum.
Ohje.
Ich find's nicht. Was, Google war das Richtige dabei?
Ernsthaft, wo?
Wo?
Das erste?
Nein.
Aus irgendwelchen Sekunden find ich meine Weihnachtsbaum-Beleuchtung nicht, also kann ich euch hier nichts zeigen.
Twitter hat ja keine Möglichkeit mehr.
Hat ja keine Möglichkeit mehr, dass man Sachen durchsetzt. Gut, dann nicht.
Weiß nicht, wo das ist.
Ja, aber die hatte ich ja letztes Jahr selbst gebaut, die RGB-Weihnachtsbaum-Beleuchtung.
Sie haben ja sogar im Stream ein bisschen drum gebastelt.
Wo hast du die Shelley-Sachen bestellt? Direkt bei Shelley. Direkt bei den Shelley. Cloud.
Direkt bei denen. Das kommt dann aus Bulgarien oder Ukraine oder so.
Irgendwie ost-östliches Europa.
Hab ich direkt bei denen bestellt.
Die hier.
Guck mal, der PC Lustig hat's gefunden. Ich bin immer wieder begeistert,
wie der Twitch-Chat besser meinen Twitter findet als ich selbst.
Und was können die hier? Das ist ein WLAN-Relay im Endeffekt.
Du kannst sie einbauen und unter Putz in die Dose bei einem Lichtschalter.
Und dann kannst du das Licht über das Relay schalten, quasi über den Tablet oder deine Heimautomatisierung
und auch weiterhin über deinen Schalter.
Genau, das ist meine Weihnachtsbaum-Beleuchtung hier, die ich gebastelt hab.
Wo sieht man sie denn?
Guck mal, da hinten ist der Anschluss.
5 Volt.
Guck mal, mein mickrischer Weihnachtsbau.
Jaja, Max, nerv nicht.
Guck, da ist er.
Da ist er in so einem IP65-Gehäuse drin.
Ja, Max, jetzt mach doch mal an.
Du hast da unten irgendwie im Topf rum zu...
Ah, jetzt wird das reingesteckt.
Steck's rein.
Und der blinkt rot, bis er WLAN-Verbindung hat.
Und dann geht er an.
Ja, und da war richtig big brain die Logik dahinter.
Der war richtig big brain.
Man erkennt es jetzt auf dem Handy nicht so gut.
Die RGB-LEDs, jede RGB-LED kriegt ein bisschen eine minimal andere Farbe.
So der Verlauf hier.
Und die pulsieren auch ganz leicht.
Also sie flackern nicht wie Kerzen.
Die werden ganz leicht, jede RGB-LED immer heller und dunkler.
Das macht es ein bisschen dynamischer, sieht dann besser aus.
Es wäre besser, wenn ich einen größeren, dichteren Baum hätte.
Dann würde man die Kabel nicht sehen.
Der hat auch noch verschiedene Programme, die man einstellen kann.
Weiß nicht, ob ich das jetzt zeige in dem Video.
Man kann es nämlich noch...
Twitter, please.
Ah genau, das ist das Web-Interface.
Man kann das über das Handy mit dem Browser einstellen.
War das der günstigste Baum oder der letzte?
Gar kein gekaufter Baum.
Das ist einer, der wächst auf der Wiese im Garten.
Da ist er einfach so gewachsen.
Und da haben wir den genommen und in den Topf gesetzt.
Genau, mein big brain Web-Interface hier.
So, bunt, stell mal bunt ein.
Oder hell oder was auch immer.
Bunt.
Und jetzt hat es nicht funktioniert, weil mein Handy ist nicht...
Ah doch.
Das ist der Party-Modus für Silvester.
Schön vor dem Gemälde im Westflügel.
Ah, yes.
Ja.
Was ich cool finde, dass man mittlerweile so Sachen relativ easy selbst bauen kann,
dass es auch alle möglichen Controller und Sachen gibt,
die erschwinglich sind.
Gerade dank AliExpress und China.
Ach ja, hat man...
Echt, sieht man meinen Access-Point.
Wahrscheinlich sieht man meinen Access-Point.
Da, guck mal.
Wieder ein Access-Point, da ist er.
Cool, Fini21, dass du das so schnell erkannt hast,
dass hier einer der WLAN-Access-Points steht in der Ecke.
Und danebenbei steht noch der Raspberry Pi,
daneben noch ein Raspberry Pi, der für die Kameras zuständig ist.
Lull.
Okay.
Ähm, gucken wir mal das Video weiter.
Also der hat einen Dimmer, den Dimmer habe ich nicht.
Das einzige, was ich dimmen kann, ist meine Weihnachtsbaumbeleuchtung.
What?
Das ist ein Smart-Müll-Eimer, sowas brauche ich.
Eigentlich komplett überflüssig.
Der Trash ist ja gar nicht smart.
Wenn das jetzt eine Presse wäre,
überlegt euch mal, wie geil es wäre,
hätte man einen Smart-Müll-Eimer mit Presse.
Das wäre richtig geil.
Da müsste man nicht so oft rausgehen.
Ansonsten ist es einfach kompletter Schwachsinn.
Ja.
Ähm.
Ansonsten ist es eigentlich 21.
Übrigens mal ganz schamlose Eigenwärmung.
Wenn euch das Stream gefällt,
ich bin jeden Sonntag am Start mit so einer Art Stream.
Unter der Woche auch mit anderem Technik-Kram.
Also ihr könnt mir gerne ein Follow da lassen.
Auch mal auf Twitter vorbeigucken.
Auf YouTube lohnt sich aktuell ja eher weniger.
Da habe ich ja schon monatelang nichts gemacht.
Turbo3400 abonniert Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön.
Excellent Subscription.
Aber ich freue mich
über jedes Follow.
Oder natürlich auch über jeden, der im Chat am Start ist.
Weil eins muss ich ja echt mal wieder loswerden.
Der Chat ist wieder big brain heute.
Ja, das ist sinnlos. Das bringt es nicht.
F.
F-Tier.
Okay.
Nur heute, ja.
Also es gab schon Tage, da war der Chat
eher
in die Richtung.
Pure Savage. Zwei Monate.
Dankeschön. Excellent.
IQ. Mit jedem Sub geht der IQ hoch.
Das merkt man wieder richtig heute.
Aber meistens ist der Chat big brain.
Meistens. Aber Ausrutscher gibt es immer.
Ne.
Echoes habe ich keine Ahnung.
Der Hype Train.
Der Scam Train ist unterwegs, Leute.
Neo aus Unterstadt.
Zwei Monate.
Dankeschön.
Ja.
Neo aus Unterstadt. Zwei Monate.
Dankeschön. Excellent Sub.
Der Scam Train ist
am Fahren hier.
Was bringt der Hype Train?
Geld für Twitch.
Du kriegst Emotes.
Das ist das einzige was bringt.
Also du kriegst Emotes, wenn du
Subs während der Hype Train läuft.
Twitch Money im Endeffekt.
Big brain white curved screen.
Ami Steckdosen.
Hell yeah. Freedom Steckdosen.
Ja. Rock Twitch Prime.
Dankeschön.
Excellent.
Warum will man überhaupt
UniFi Firewalls haben?
Äh.
UniFi Access Points POG.
UniFi
Der UniFi der Ubiquiti
10G Switch ist auch POG.
Weil er kein UniFi Switch ist.
Sondern ganz normaler Edge
Switch mit normalem Web Interface.
Aber für alles andere.
Für die Access Points
mag ich die UniFi Geschichte.
Ansonsten
ist nicht so mein Fall.
Ich höre ja auf Mikrotik.
Oh.
So was?
Oh jetzt was ist das?
Boah.
Das ist...
Poggers.
Das hat er selbst gebaut.
So was gibt's nicht fertig. Das hat er selbst gebaut.
Ich hab auch... Ich hab auch so was.
Allerdings für die...
für die Rollladen.
Die vorne hin zur Straße gehen.
Die sind noch Oldschool-Rollladen aus Holz
mit Kurbel dran.
Und dafür hab ich mir sowas hier gekauft.
Äh.
Irgendwie sowas da.
Ich bin mir nicht ganz sicher
welche...die billigen.
Die billigen hab ich mir gekauft.
Brauch ich ja nur
zwei Stück.
Drei Stück.
Vier Stück hab ich. Genau.
Vier Stück. Ähm.
Die lassen nämlich dort rein,
wo die...
normalen
Roller auch schon drin sind.
Das heißt, die siehst du danach nicht mehr.
Da guckt halt nur das hier raus.
Und das Beste daran ist...
Ähm. Ne, da musst gucken, dass du die billiger kriegst.
Also ich würd mir nicht die 120 Euro Variante kaufen.
Aber das Beste daran ist,
dass man sie nicht...
Ähm.
...
Genau. Das Beste ist, man muss sie nicht mit der offiziellen App
und nicht von Hand steuern, weil
es gibt...
...
Kann man von Raspberry Pi nehmen und gut ist.
Oder du kaufst den Cloud Key, das könntest du auch machen.
Fürs Trollen gestern, wieso, so schlimm war das jetzt auch nicht.
Ja, da hat er recht.
Heading out to the patio, you're going to have to pardon my dust, since I'm in the middle of a major construction project.
But a few of my favorite things are out here.
Motorized roller shades provide some relief from the late day sun that blasts the patio.
And even though the stepper motors that drive these shades aren't indoor rated,
they're still going strong after three years.
The pool is also automated with Amazon Echo and responds to commands like turn on the hot tub or turn on the pool light.
My daughter and her friends get a surprising amount of music.
Moin, Bush, Meta.
Wenn man einen Pool hat, das Problem ist, man braucht erstmal einen Pool.
Ich hab nur einen Fischteich, glaub da zählt das nicht.
Landscape lighting using LED strips was a project that I just kind of attempted on a whim,
but it turned out to be amazing, at least from my view.
We have a large concrete wall and palm tree stand behind our screen pool, so it's not an issue at all.
But if you had rear neighbors, I could see how they would be very annoyed looking at it from the opposite direction.
RGB landscape lighting gets more use than holiday lighting and it looks great.
So I think it belongs somewhere at the bottom of the beach here.
Freie.
Wer will denn sowas?
Was ist mit Open Hub für Smart Home?
Wenn man auf Java Sachen steht, dann ist Open Hub gut.
Ich fand's zu kompliziert und der Community, also der Drive dahinter ist jetzt auch nicht so hoch wie bei anderen Sachen.
Aber wenn man Java mag, ist Open Hub nicht verkehrt.
Ich persönlich mag Home Assistant.
Es gibt noch ein paar andere Sachen, aber Home Assistant ist so das Produkt, da ist sehr viel Community und sehr viel Action dahinter, was passiert.
Ubiquiti hat beispielsweise die Home Assistant Entwicklung auch mal ein dreiviertel Jahr lang gesponsort.
Ja, Atro, Trom, so sieht's aus.
Ja, da hab ich keinen Anwendungszweck für.
Also bei mir gibt's wenig Smart Lighting.
Nicht Lightning, Lighting.
Ich spiele da gerade Just Dance.
Kennt ihr noch das Friseurvideo?
Kennt ihr noch das Video vom Fabian?
Just Dance?
Wie hieß das denn?
Wo ist das Just Dance Video vom Fabian?
Dance, Dance, Dance Revolution, genau.
Excellent.
Da ist der Fabian am Start.
Das ist voll krass am Upmoven.
Zu geil.
Poggers.
Der hat sich sowas getraut, der Fabian.
Ich hätte mich im Leben nicht getraut, ein Dance Video aufzunehmen, Alter.
Zu geil, ey.
Das steht bei mir noch an.
Also kein Ecobee, sondern das Steuern von der Heizung.
Ich hab ja an meiner Heizung unten im Keller einen Raspberry Pi dran,
dass ich die Daten auslesen kann.
Ich könnte da drüber auch was setzen, aber will ich ehrlich gesagt nicht.
Wer weiß, ob ich da irgendeinen Mist einstelle.
Ich hab mir einen Sea-Wave-Thermostat für die Heizung gekauft.
Da kann man quasi die Heizungsregel mit.
Ich hab aber noch kein gescheites Konzept, wie man das macht.
Weil da muss ja schon ein bisschen Logik dahinter.
Zum Beispiel, wenn die Klimaanlage angeht,
dass er dann auch auf jeden Fall die Heizung ausschalten und solche Dinge.
Dass man nicht so komische Sachen machen kann, die keinen Sinn ergeben.
Da hab ich mich noch nicht drum gekümmert.
Das steht noch an.
Der Friseur ist recht wenig auf Twitch in letzter Zeit.
Ich hab gehört, da spielt gerade Diablo auf der Switch.
Lohne.
Ja.
Stopp schon.
was ich Smart nennen würde, aber es klingt an den Gaget-Lover an.
Die Kauke klingelt mit Motoren.
Und bevor du sagst, das ist völlig wertlos,
eine einzelne Handel macht den Job schneller als die Kauke.
Du bist nicht falsch, aber der Hauptwunsch
für einen Motorer ist die Kauke.
... ist komplette Kontrolle und die Möglichkeit,
den Kopfrest und den Fußrest freizuführen.
Ich wollte diese automatisieren,
aber nach dem Mechanismus, den ich gefahren habe,
habe ich einen ziemlich schlechten Plan entschieden,
da die linearen Atuatoren
die Bohnen auf die Klappe
wenn die Klappe geschlossen wird.
Motorerische Kauke, C-Tier sicherlich.
In der Gäste-Ruhung, Play-Ruhung,
Weis-Office,
öffnen und schließen die Blüten morgens und nachts.
Bevor sie automatisiert wurden,
haben wir sie geschlossen,
da die Privacität in diesem Ort ein Problem ist,
aber es ist schön, etwas mehr Licht im Raum zu bekommen.
Es gibt auch RGB-LEDs über dem Murphy-Bed
und einen Unify-Axispunkt.
Aus dem Garage.
Das beeindruckendste Projekt hier war
eine Smart-Garage-Dauer,
die eigentlich mein erstes DIY-Holm-Automation-Projekt war.
Eine Relay lässt man
mit dem Open- oder Closed-Button
auf der Haupt-Unit, um die Tür zu operieren.
Und ein einfaches Read-Switch
nutzt ein Magnet, um zu sehen, ob die Garage-Dauer geöffnet ist.
Das erinnert die Frage, ob man
die Garage-Dauer geschlossen hat.
Die Garage-Dauer-Automation ist super nützlich,
aber es hat keinen Sinn,
weil die Garage
nicht als Garage verwendet wird,
sondern als Abstell-Ort.
Also in der Garage,
im Hof, ist es nicht so, dass man da das Auto
rein und raus fährt, sondern die ist komplett voll
mit Zeug.
Das heißt, die wird selten auf und zu gemacht.
Hat sich bei mir nicht gelohnt.
Der kröne Lambo-Genie, ja.
Von 2001.
Echt? Das ist EFT hier?
Ach so, der meint jetzt explizit dieses Gerät,
was es nicht wert ist.
Weil ich muss sagen, der...
Was ist denn?
ESP866, glaube ich,
den ich unten im Keller habe, der
komplett verbraucht zählt
und vom ersten Stock,
der finde ich eigentlich ganz praktisch,
ab und zu mal auf den Stromverbrauch zu gucken.
Da kann man nämlich richtig sehen, so nach dem Motto,
wann geht warm Wasser an, wann wird Essen gemacht
und solche Geschichten.
Vor allem kann man auch mal sehen,
wenn man guckt nachts,
wie ist der Verbrauch nachts so,
und stellt fest, okay,
warum sind es nachts irgendwie 400, 500 Watt,
auf einmal, wo kommen die her?
Und dann sagt man, okay, ich sollte vielleicht
mal die Heizung von meinem Klo ausstellen
oder sowas.
Das bringt auch was.
Was jetzt kein Witz ist, ich hab das wirklich aus Versehen angehabt,
beziehungsweise falsch eingestellt,
das kann ja
das Wasser heizen,
das Klo, und
man kann das so einstellen,
dass der nie heizt,
oder man kann das so einstellen, dass er anfängt
zu heizen, wenn man sich drauf setzt,
oder man kann das einstellen, dass er
immer heizt. So. Und ich war so
low-brain und hab eingestellt, er soll
immer heizen. Das heißt, mein Klo
hat permanent, den ganzen Tag über,
auch im Winter, das Wasser auf
angenehme Temperaturen geheizt,
falls man sich den Poppes abspülen will,
was komplett sinnlos ist.
Wenn man sich nämlich den Poppes abspülen will,
dann sitzt man vorher 4, 5 Minuten drauf,
weil man halt mal ne Runde kacken muss.
Und in der Zeit kann der auch heizen.
Das hat richtig, richtig
Geld gespart, dass ich das erkannt hab.
Das Spülwasser wärmen.
Nein, nicht das Spülwasser.
Das Wasser, was man verwendet,
wo man sich den Poppes mit absprayt.
Wer ist denn so lange kacken?
Wenn du so nen angenehmen Klo hast wie ich,
dann kannst du ohne Probleme 5 bis 10 Minuten scheißen.
Kein Problem.
Der hat auch die Möglichkeit,
dass man es verwendet als
Intimenspülung,
aber mach ich nicht. Ich verwende das bloß zum Poppes
absprayen.
Ihr kennt das Video doch, oder?
Moment. Klo.
Kack FPS, da ist es doch.
Hier ist das Klo, da.
Ja, Klo.
Spülung.
Föhn hintern, das fährt dann so aus.
Föhn zum
trocken machen.
Den Föhn verwende ich nicht, das mach ich immer mit Klo-Papier.
Ich mag das Föhn nicht.
Beschichtung, dass nichts hängen bleibt.
Absenk, Automatik
und neben,
weiß nicht, ob ich es irgendwo
zeige, wo die Fernbedienung drin ist.
Moment, hier.
Neben.
Mehr wert als dein Auto.
Oh ja, viel mehr wert als mein Auto.
Neben hast du eine Fernbedienung drin, stecken unten
noch Knöpfe für Spülung
und Wasserintensität.
Kann man das auch smart machen?
Ja, nicht so richtig.
Nicht so richtig.
Was man machen kann, ist, man könnte hier eine LED,
einen Foto-Resistor
hinmachen, der erkennt,
wenn
es angeht, bzw.
wenn es
Wartung braucht, also wenn man Spülflüssigkeit
nachfüllen muss oder sowas, aber
ansonsten kann man nicht viel machen.
Zumindest, ich zeige es euch mal am Ende, wie das aussieht,
dass es die, oh, oh, Marks Haare liegt.
Genau.
Das ist die Fernbedienung.
Da kann man hier einstellen.
Abzug.
Das ist eines der praktischsten
Features überhaupt.
Das hat einen Abzug.
Also sprich, das zieht
was macht die Dame vorne spülen?
Normale Spülung
ist hinten spülen, Damenspülung ist vorne
spülen. Und das hier
zieht quasi
die Luft
raus
im Klo. Das heißt, es stinkt nicht im Bad.
Sehr praktisch, sehr praktisch.
Wie ich gerne.
Okta-Core.
Genau, hier sieht man ein bisschen die Sachen. Und das ist
den Fehler, den ich gemacht habe. Genau.
Man kann nämlich die Heizung von dem Wasser einstellen.
Aus,
nur an, wenn man drauf sitzt, oder immer
an. Wenn ich frage,
was der Mario-Geist hier macht, das ist meine Handy-Hülle
von damals.
Ich gucke mal, genau, das ist Intensität
vom Wasser, bla bla.
Jetzt, Moment, jetzt fährt er aus.
Wo fährt er aus?
Hier, guck.
Da, Wasserstrahl.
So sieht das
aus. Wenn man fertig ist,
wenn man fertig ist, drückt man drauf
und dann kommt das Wasser hier rausgefahren und macht
Eimer und spülende
Bobes ab. Und je nachdem,
wie fest man das einstellt,
wird auch bis zu
unangenehm fest.
Gibt der Leute, vielleicht mögen sie das.
So, und danach,
wenn der fertig spülen ist, kommt ein Föhn
rausgefahren und
pustet den Bobes ab. Ah, nee.
Jetzt
zeige ich noch den Föhn.
Max, Föhn?
Nein, das ist nochmal die
Spülung gewesen.
Max, zeig den Föhn.
Da, da ist der Föhn.
Ja, damit geföhnet.
Den benutze ich aber nicht, das dauert mir zu lang.
Ich putze da immer nochmal Runde mit Klopapier
ab, gut ist.
Äußerst praktisch.
Und definitiv
definitiv mehr
Restwert als mein Auto, ja, das stimmt.
Weißt du noch, was das
gekostet hat? Ja, irgendwie...
Was kostet das?
Aqua Clean 800 Plus.
Gucken, was es jetzt kostet.
Oh, nee, nee, nee, nee, so viel hat es
nicht gekostet.
Ich glaube, das ist
ein Auslaufgerät, deswegen ist es jetzt
so teuer.
So, also ganz so viel hat es nicht gekostet,
das weiß ich. Wow, warum...
Boah, nein, nein, nein,
so teuer war das nicht.
Ich würde sagen, eher so in dem Dreh.
Irgendwie so 2500 Euro
oder sowas.
Also, es ist
schon unsinnig
teuer eigentlich, aber wenn man sich
überlegt, es ist ein bisschen wie ein guter
Bürostuhl.
Es gibt
Sachen,
da lohnt sich die Investition
oder lohnt sich ein bisschen mehr Geld
auszugeben, weil wenn man mal in sich geht
und überlegt, wie viele Stunden man
diese Sachen verwendet
in seinem Leben, ist
das Geld doch nicht schlecht aufgehoben.
Also sprich,
wenn man sich das halbwegs
leisten kann, auch wenn man
vielleicht ein bisschen geizig ist, kann man sich mal überwenden
und sagen, okay, einen guten Bürostuhl
kaufen, ein gutes Klo kaufen, ist
keine Verschwendung des Geldes.
Klopapier-Notlage
Anfang von Corona.
Ja, die Klopapier-
Corona-Notlage
hat mich ja mit dem Klo eh schon nicht so
sehr getroffen und außerdem habe ich mir am Internet
eine Palette Klopapier bestellt.
Also Palette,
war es nicht, das war eine
10er-Pack oder so.
Halbe Palette.
Habe ich
kein Anwendungszweck für,
mein Rasen im Garten
wird nicht gesprinkelt.
Das ist ja auch eher so eine Unkrautwiese.
Ihr kennt
aus dem Ausbau,
das ist ja auch eher so eine Unkrautwiese.
Habe ich kein Anwendungszweck für,
mein Rasen im Garten
wird nicht gesprinkelt.
Ihr kennt aus dem Garten
vielleicht noch der eine oder andere.
Da wird nichts gesprinkelt.
Hast du von Mark Rober das Eichhörnchen-Video gesehen?
Ich habe auf YouTube recherchiert und es sah so aus,
als ob alle Hotrod-Kanäle mit ihren
Burina-LED-Fixtures sehr glücklich seien.
Ich habe ein Set von 12-18 Dollar gekauft.
Und ich habe nicht wirklich gedacht, wie breit
12-20 Watt 6500K-LEDs
sein würden.
Mit all den Lichtern könnte man jemanden
fulgieren, wenn er dachte, dass sie außerhalb
im direkten Sonnenlicht waren.
Also um mich zu verhindern,
habe ich sie in Banks genutzt,
mit einem Shelly-1, wo ich zwei immer-on-Lichter
mit dem Lichtswitch kontrolliere,
und einen ECHO-Kommand, um die anderen 10 Lichter
aufzulegen, wenn ich aufstehe.
Okay, zurück ins Haus und nach oben.
Alle ECHO-Kanälen haben
Magnetik-Kanälen-Sensoren, die ich total liebe.
Wir benutzen diese Sensor
auf meiner Tochter, um zu wissen, ob sie
bei uns nachts dabei ist.
So, und
dann gucke ich unten, bevor ich aus dem Haus gehe,
gucke ich aufs Tablet, aufs Dashboard drauf
und sehe alle Fenster zu,
und ich muss nicht nochmal durchs Haus gehen.
Funktioniert das auch mit der Eingangstür, klar?
Ist auch an der Eingangstür dran.
Das ist die Eingangstür.
Kids.
Der hat schon Kids.
Der will schon Kids.
Ja, ich weiß, es gibt genug.
Hast du schon gefrühstückt? Ja, aber ich wollte jetzt seit über einer Stunde schon mal eine Nudel essen, die jetzt kalt neben mir stehen.
Max setzt Kinder in die Welt. Ne, im Leben nicht.
Das scheitert ja schon an zwei Sachen. Erstens, ich mag keine Kinder, also ich mag an sich keine Menschen und Kinder ganz besonders nicht.
Und außerdem gibt es niemanden mit, wo ich das machen könnte gerade.
Also es fehlen ja schon zwei wichtige Grundvoraussetzungen dafür.
Und ich kann mir mich auch nicht als Vater vorstellen.
Könnt ihr euch ernsthaft einen 35-jährigen Typ als Vater vorstellen, der im Real Life Poggers sagt?
Könnt ihr euch das wirklich vorstellen?
Poggers feels Batman, Alter.
Bin ich dann im Kindergarten oder? Ich bin in der Schule. Eltern Sprechtag.
Eltern Sprechtag. Und da kommt dann die Englischlehrerin und sagt ihr, also ihr Sohn in Englisch, da muss man noch was machen.
Da sagt ihr, feels Batman. Und da kommt der andere an, ja aber hier in IT ist er richtig gut. Poggers.
Kann ich mir richtig vorstellen gerade.
Ja, also der kleine Max, der ist, also sagen wir so irgendwie, ja also Kunst liegt im Jahrfall. Feels good man, feels good man.
Keg W.
Mir rutschten so Sachen ja manchmal schon auf der Arbeit raus, ne.
Kann mich noch dran erinnern, hatten wir letztens irgendwie auf der Teamrunde, meinte einer neuen Server, neuen Fireballs sind da.
Und da hab ich wirklich gesagt, Pog, oder Poggers, Poggers.
Ach naja.
Ob dein Kind dann überhaupt Deutsch kann oder nur Emotes sprechen kann, also wahrscheinlich, wahrscheinlich kann mein Kind noch, bevor er ordentlich Deutsch oder irgendeine andere Sprache kann, die Basic Twitch Emotes.
Das lacht nicht, das keckt.
Wo andere Kinder dann lachen, sagt mein Kinder nur auch Keg W, Keg W, Keg W.
Kappa. Jetzt hab ich im Video gar nicht aufgepasst.
Ne, Kappa ist nicht so meine Emote, Kappa finde ich nicht, das ist outdated.
Und zumindest bekommt mein Kind keine Brille, weil es sie scharpt ja.
Oh, das war so schlecht.
Smart switches are moving up closer to the A-Tier, because they let you tie in a bunch of devices together and switch devices that aren't physically connected to each other in the same electrical circuit.
The studio slash home gym slash kids guest room has some smart switches and dimmers that tie the...
Oh, 3D-Drucker. Was hat er für ein 3D-Drucker?
The studio slash home gym slash kids guest room...
Äh, erkennt man nicht so richtig.
Ist das überhaupt ein... Ja, das ist ein 3D-Drucker, oder? Sieht irgendwie... Ja, ja, ja, hier neben mit der...
Die Dead-Shock sahst du schon drauf, ja, das stimmt.
Bester Witz, wo wir gerade bei schlechten Witze sind. Treffen sich zwei Jäger, beide tot.
Das zeigt richtig schlecht, ey.
Smart switches and dimmers that tie the ceiling fan light to the...
War der Witz nicht auch wow, ne?
These that are above the Murphy bed and the shelving unit. But that's about it.
In my daughter's bathroom, the only smart device is a Bluetooth shower light speaker connected to an Amazon Echo Flex...
Boah, alter, der hat ja sein ganzes Haus mit Amazon Echo voll.
Da würde ich traumlich auf die Idee kommen, mir über... Sogar... Sogar...
Ins Bad. Na gut, im Bad ist noch das Mini, das Ding hat ja keine Kamera.
Aber trotzdem, ne.
The master bedroom, excellent.
Oh, beste. Den hab ich auch, den hab ich auch.
Ja, Poggers, bester.
Mich würd interessieren, ob er Custom-Firmware verwendet oder die originalen China-Firmware.
Ja, definitiv. Das ist eines der praktischsten Sachen ever.
Also ich find sein Setup gut, it's approved, so.
Ice Freak, 10 Monate, dankeschön.
Ups, eigentlich hab ich voll verklickt. Das wollt ich klicken. Reicht schon für den Zap.
Muss man für die Custom-Firmware auf dem Schiff gehen?
Muss man für die Custom-Firmware auf dem Staubsauger programmieren können? Ne.
Ne, ne, ne. Roborock S50. S50 oder S5, das ist das gleiche.
S55 nicht und auch kein S6, der funktioniert die Custom-Firmware nämlich nicht.
S5 und S50, das ist das gleiche.
W? Hab ich grad W?
W was?
Das ist richtig cool. Irgendwann bau ich sowas auch mal.
Wenn ich irgendwo noch halbwegs einen sinnvollen Anwendungszweck für RGB-Beleuchtung hab,
dann ist es tatsächlich im Schlafzimmer, weil ich mir das schon cool vorstelle,
wenn du so einen Sonnenaufgang simulieren kannst oder auch wenn du nachts mal aus Klo musst,
dass du so eine Mini-Beleuchtung anmachen kannst oder so.
Und man könnte es auch noch ganz anders machen. Man könnte sogar einen Sensor erstellen,
sobald man auf, also der checkt, ob jemand im Bett liegt und wenn man dann aufsteht
und es quasi nachts ist, dass es dann automatisch die Beleuchtung anmacht.
Man muss mit dem Sensor plus aufpassen, je nachdem, nicht dass der permanentes Licht an-
und ausgeht. Aber wenn man einfach nur drinnen liegt, dann sollte das nicht passieren.
Oh, Chet, Ygit, Sensor, ob die Blase voll ist, MonkaS, da will ich gar nicht dran denken, Ygit.
Oh, ne, Chet.
Erinnert mich an den einen Typ, der sich sein RFID-Chip unter die Haut gespritzt hat.
Letztens im Video gesehen von einem der Home-Automation-Channels, die ich gucke,
und er hat sich eine Spritze gekauft mit so einem aufgerollten RFID-Chip
und die hat er sich unter die Haut über der Hand gespritzt.
Das fand ich auch nicht. Sobald ich mir RFID-Chips unter die Haut spritze,
dann hört es bei mir auf. Ich bin technikaffin, aber so übertreiben muss ich es dann auch nicht.
Hat er auch ein Open Hub Raspberry Pi, keine Ahnung, was der für ein System verwendet.
Das ist cool, aber jetzt mal ganz im Ernst.
Also so als Tipp, was man wahrscheinlich nur auf die Idee kommt, wenn man nicht aus den USA kommt.
Es gibt die Möglichkeit, dass wenn die Luftfeuchtigkeit im Bad hoch ist, dass man einfach das Fenster aufmacht.
Hab ich gehört, soll helfen. Aber ich glaube, da kommt man im Konkret,
nicht auf die Idee. Da macht man lieber die Klimaanlage an, um die Luftfeuchtigkeit zu beseitigen,
anstatt das Fenster aufzumachen.
Ach du Scheiße, da hat er überall Amazon Echo.
Schaue Alexa, what the fuck.
Trotzdem, gutes Video, sehr gutes Video.
Da sieht man, dass die Leute unterschiedliche Prioritäten legen beim Thema Smartphone.
Er steht total auf Echo, er steht total auf Alexa, er will irgendwie Musik über Alexa beim Duschen anmachen können,
beim Kacken, was auch immer. Ich habe halt andere Prioritäten, was Heimautomatisierung angeht.
So Leute, ich muss jetzt unbedingt was essen. Wir haben jetzt zwei Möglichkeiten.
Entweder wir gucken jetzt noch ein Barbecue Pit Boys Video und ich esse dabei was.
Ach so, das mag, okay, welches Video? Moment, wo war der Link? Du hast gepostet.
Ich habe es gesehen irgendwo. Ich finde es aber nicht mehr. Ach hier.
Okay, dann gucken wir uns jetzt noch kurz Eichhörnchen Video an, aber ich habe keine Ahnung von was das war.
Oh, 21 Minuten, fuck.
What the fuck?
Ja, wenn man 12 Millionen Abos auf YouTube hat, kann man den ganzen Tag Birds watchen.
Erfinderisch ist es ja.
Okay Chat, Chat, das widerspricht sich jetzt. Das Video ist nicht wirklich gut.
Nächste Chat Message, das Video ist richtig nice.
Ja, was denn jetzt?
Da habe ich mal voll Ärger gekriegt. Ich glaube, das habe ich schon mal erzählt.
Dass ich mit der Gabel so oft gegen meine Zähne kommen soll beim Essen.
Hat sich mal jemand voll aufgeregt. Das geht nicht mehr essen.
Ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die Zähne die Zähne ausmachen können, aber mal sehen.
Ja, das geht auch, jetzt fällt alles raus.
Also eigentlich hätte ich jetzt eher erwartet, nachdem es ja ein Video aus den USA ist.
Ich hätte eigentlich eher erwartet, dass das dann selbst, genau Blockwatcher, die gleiche Idee hatte ich auch.
Warum macht er keine Selbstschussanlage daneben?
Das wäre der Kokona-Way. Kiefkern, 10 Monate, Dankeschön.
Also der richtige Kokona-Way wäre eindeutig, Selbstschussanlage, mit AI-Bilderkennung, ob es ein Eichhörnchen ist oder nicht.
Sowas gibt es dort bestimmt.
Okay Leute, die kalten Nudeln schmecken nicht wirklich gut.
Damit ich das essen kann, muss ich jetzt noch ein bisschen Parmesankiss drüber machen.
Ansonsten halte ich das dann aus.
Baguette, Tomatenbrot.
Was?
Darf man sowas überhaupt?
Also in Deutschland könnte den garantiert der Typ, der das Paket geklaut hat, verklagen.
Nicht in Deutschland, was labere ich für ein Scheiß. In den USA könnte den garantierter Typ verklagen, dass er ihn vollgesprayt hat.
Das ist eine tolle Konstruktion.
Ähm, hätte man das nicht deutlich einfacher machen können?
Wenn sein Ziel ist, dass nur Vögel dran kommen, keine Eichhörnchen, hätte man das nicht einfach irgendwo dran hängen können, wo Eichhörnchen nicht hochkommen oder nicht lang können?
Also, keine Ahnung.
Eine Mast mit etwas längerem Draht dran oder so.
Also, Roffel 1, 4, 3, 6, die kommen schon gut überall hoch. Ich hatte mal ein Eichhörnchen im Wohnzimmer unten.
Das ist durch die Eingangstür rein, weil es hat wohl übelst Hunger gehabt und war dann im Wohnzimmer und ich habe versucht einzufangen mit einem Fisch, mit einem Netz für Fische habe ich versucht einzufangen.
Also mit so einem Netz, wo man eigentlich Dreck und sowas aus dem Fischteich macht.
Und das konnte wirklich senkrecht an der Tapete hochklettern.
Und Kescher, sowas, ja.
Ok.
Ist das?
Ah.
Ok.
Wann sieht man denn?
Peter ist informiert.
Oh.
Guck mal, ein ESP32.
Ah.
Der sollte den Kurs nochmal bauen, sodass er heran besicher ist.
Nicht blöd, die lernen es.
Outplayed, outplayed.
Ha.
Der cheatet, der cheatet.
Die cheaten bestimmt und gehen oben lang.
Ja.
Ha.
Also wenn mal der Höhlen im Eichhörnchen was passiert, dann wäre auch irgendwas nicht ganz richtig.
Ok, any height habe ich so meine Zweifel.
Ha.
So, ich habe jetzt in halbem Challenge gegessen, jetzt geht es mir besser.
Das war echt übertrieben, oder?
Ah, das ist ja auch fies.
Das ist ja auch fies.
Was soll es denn da sonst machen, außer raus zu gucken und zu futtern?
Ha.
Huge Resolution.
Vielleicht ist es gar kein...
Grill.
Grill Eichhörnchen.
Das ist ziemlich gut.
Ja.
Sag mal, Moment, können die nicht...
Warum können die nicht einfach von hier runter hüpfen?
Wenn die doch angeblich überall heim hinkommen?
Das hier wird doch nicht zu weit sein.
Das ist von oben nach unten.
Das machen die nur, weil der Weg mit Nüssen voll voll ist, sonst würden die direkt weiter
dahinspringen.
Ha.
Okay.
Also hätte er das rote nicht rumgemacht, da wäre der Durchschnitt YouTube-Zuschauer
nicht in der Lage gewesen, das Eichhörnchen hier zu erkennen.
Unmöglich.
Wo ist das Eichhörnchen?
Ich sehe es nicht.
Nicht zu erkennen.
Nicht dein.
Nicht zu sehen.
Da fliegt das.
Das muss er wahrscheinlich jetzt nochmal so in Ruhe zeigen, sonst kommt Peter an und
fliegt auf.
Er ist ja auch klar, dass sie so eine schnelle Reaktion haben, weil ich meinte, dass er
vom Kopf zum Fuß viel kürzer ist als bei uns.
Das ist übrigens auch der Grund, warum schwarze Löcher rotieren, aber real big brain talk
jetzt.
Das ist der gleiche Grund, warum schwarze Löcher rotieren.
Das ist kein Witz jetzt.
Schwarze Löcher entstehen aus einem Stern, der am Ende seiner Lebensdauer in sich zusammenfällt,
und wenn der sich dreht und quasi von relativ groß zu relativ, also sehr schnell relativ
klein wird, dann bleibt der Drehimpuls erhalten.
Deswegen drehen sich schwarze Löcher.
Max Lash.
So weit sind wir noch nicht.
Wow.
Big brain chomp.
Aber jetzt kann er sich doch gar keine Vögel mehr angucken.
Wow.
Wer hätte das gedacht, dass auch Eichhörnchen interessant sein können, wenn man sie sich mal
anguckt.
Je nachdem wie lang, ich könnte mir meine Katze auch den halben Tag angucken.
Aber naja, nee, nee, kann ich nicht, weil die schläft den halben Tag.
Die Insel vielleicht.
Spoda.
Okay, war doch gar nicht so schlimm das Video, wie ich gedacht habe.
Nein, nein, nein, das ist keine Werbung machen.
Durch das eine 37 Minuten Video, wo ich mich zwei Stunden drüber ausgelassen habe, haben
wir sonst kaum was anderes geguckt.
Der Typ sieht so mega Influenza mäßig schon aus, ist er aber gar nicht.
Mit freundlicher Unterstützung von Aldi Süd.
Ah, exzellent.
Kenn ich nicht.
Hab ich noch nie gehabt.
Oh, das ist ein Resident-Sleeper-Video.
Ah, blablabla.
Okay, wann geht's denn los?
Yo, technischer Service, Endkundensupport.
Es gibt ja kaum was Schlimmeres.
MonkaS, Endkundensupport.
Da kümmerst du dich dann um die Wünsche deiner Kunden und suchst nach der perfekten Lösung
für ihre Ansprüche.
Dafür nimmst du dann z.B.
Nein.
Nein, nein.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht geben.
Leute, ich gehe auf.
Ich esse jetzt meinen restlichen Tellernudel.
Und vielleicht bin ich heute Abend am Start.
Ubisoft, wann ist das?
Ubisoft Forward CES-T.
Top 21 Uhr.
CES-T.
9.
21 Uhr.
Okay, vielleicht bin ich heute Abend 21 Uhr am Start.
Falls man das streamen darf.
Auf das Ding sagt, ich mache eine Lehre als Systemtechniker, weil ich einfach Hardware
und Interaktion mag.
Aber der First-Level-Support ist einfach Horror.
Also generell Endkundenkontakt oder generell Kundenkontakt ist...
FeelsBatman.
Vielleicht, also wie gesagt, vielleicht machen wir die Ubisoft-Geschichte.
Mal schauen.
Max, kurze Frage.
Welches Land hat in der Sache Videospiel die Nase von Japan oder Amerika?
Boah.
Puh.
Ja, zumindest Deutschland nicht.
Da sind wir uns glaube ich einig.
Ähm.
Hm.
Keine Ahnung.
Ich hab keine Ahnung.
Kein Schimmer, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Weiß ich echt nicht.
Aber eine gute Frage, ich hab keine Antwort drauf.
Afrika.
Ja, wer kennt's nicht, die Spiel ist wieder Afrika.
Okay Leute, ich geh jetzt wirklich auf was futtern.
Wir waren ganz schön lange am Start.
Guck mal, so lange haben wir ja schon ewig nicht mal gestreamt.
4 Stunden 40 Minuten.
Poggers.
Äh, so lange ist es ganz selten, ne.
Also, wer so nicht gemacht hat, ich freu mich über jeden Follow.
Und da könnt ihr auch mal auf Twitter vorbeigucken.
Follow, follow, follow.
Ich find das immer lustig, wenn die Koreaner das aussprechen.
Follow, follow, follow, follow, follow, follow.
Naisu.
5 Stunden nichts anderes gemacht, außer zwei Videos angeschaut.
Ja, ja, so sieht's aus.
Also, wir sehen uns, bis denn.
Vielleicht heute Abend.
CU, macht's gut.